mesdames et messieurs les députés cher
collègue monsieur le premier ministre
messieurs les membres du gouvernement
avant d'appeler l'examen des questions
au gouvernement
je voudrais au nom de la représentation
nationale salué le courage et la
mobilisation des habitants de notre pays
dans les heures difficiles que nous
traversons
chaque jour en effet le noir bilan du
coronavirus alourdit un peu plus des
consignes sévères ont été données
j'observe que dans leur immense majorité
nos concitoyennes et nos concitoyens des
respecte contribuant ainsi à enrayer la
progression de la pandémie
pour autant le pays n'est pas à l'arrêt
la france lutte et le surmontera cette
épreuve
c'est pour cela que nous siégeons certes
en format très restreint mais nous
siégeons pour assurer notre mission
constitutionnelle et faire vivre notre
vie démocratique c'est pour cela aussi
que d'innombrables professionnels de
santé du secours du soin de l'aide
fonctionnaires de tous secteurs
militaires cheminots transporteurs
livreurs et tous les acteurs de la
logistique paysans ouvriers pêcheurs et
professionnels indispensables à la vie
économique et sociale de notre pays font
tous les efforts pour maintenir chaque
jour des activités essentielles ces
citoyens engagés aux côtés de tous les
autres je les salue et je sais que vous
tous ici des salué comme moi parce qu'il
travaille à sauver des vies
parce qu'il s'expose pour la
collectivité il mérite plus que notre
gratitude je veux leur dire notre
admiration
la france est forte et le prouve dans
cette confrontation avec un péril
sournois qu'il est décidé à vaincre
cette guerre car c'est une guerre
endeuillé de nombreuses familles
nous partageons leur peine nous
partageons les souffrances de toutes
celles et de tous ceux qui sont touchés
par la maladie ou qui s'inquiètent pour
un proche à voir un ami en réanimation
sans pouvoir lui rendre visite
perdre un parent sans pouvoir s'incliner
sur sa tombe
c'est un redoublement de la douleur
et cette douleur est la nôtre à nous
représentants de la nation toute entière
la pandémie a aussi endeuillé notre
république
en enlevant la vie à notre ancien
collègue patrick devedjian qui pendant
plus de trente ans soit comme député
soit comme ministre siégea dans cet
hémicycle
je n'ai pas besoin de rappeler que
l'orateur il fut tout feu tout flamme
inspirant le respect à ses adversaires
eux mêmes par l'étendue de sa culture
son indépendance d'esprit et son brio à
sa famille à ses amis à ses
collaborateurs j'adresse mes
condoléances émues de la représentation
nationale
enfin notre assemblée s'est trouvée
endeuillée par la disparition de notre
collègue jean-françois cesarini qui
luttait depuis trois années contre une
autre maladie tout aussi redoutable dans
ces derniers jours demanda encore il
mettait son expérience de patients au
service de la france
en offrant à tous un parcours numérique
pour que chacun puisse effectuer ses
démarches en ligne durant le confinement
et son dernier acte politique fut pour
saluer l'action du ministre de la santé
et des personnels soignants contre le
coc vide 19 chez jean-françois cesarini
l'altruisme aller de pair avec un
profond humanisme un humanisme en
actions qui passait par l'engagement
public
l'innovation technologique et aussi la
culture il aimait la poésie le théâtre
et la chanson
héritier des lumières il savait le
pouvoir des arts dans le progrès des
individus et des sociétés amoureux
d'avignon sa ville natale il y avait
pris fait et cause pour la fraîche et
culture au service du développement
local au palais bourbon
nous retiendrons le sourire de ce
social-démocrate citoyens du monde qui
portait haut les idéaux de fraternité
humaine je prononcerai son éloge funèbre
lors d'une prochaine séance
je vous demande de bien vouloir observer
une minute de silence
je vous remercie
l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
gouvernement
je vous rappelle que dans le contexte de
la crise actuelle la conférence des
présidents établi des règles
dérogatoires d'organisation à nos
séances de questions ne sont présents
qu'en nombre limité de ministres et un
seul député par groupe les questions
ayant le même thème sont regroupés comme
chaque question faisant l'objet d'une
réponse spécifique le nombre de
questions et réduits en revanche les
temps de parole sont les temps usuel de
minutes par question et autant par
raiponce réplique ou contre réplique
éventuellement comprises afin de limiter
au maximum les effectifs des personnels
présents
je vous indique que la liste des
orateurs dont a vu connaissance n'est
pas affichés sur les écrans durant la
séance je vous remercie de votre
compréhension
enfin les règles sanitaires désormais
habituel continue à prévaloir notamment
les mesures suivantes nettoyage des
microns pour le séance je vous rappelle
qu'il est demandé de ne pas poser les
mains sur les micro d'utiliser des
micros différents respect des distances
entre les participants entrée et sortie
échelonnée
nous commençons notre séance par des
questions portant sur la crise du coït
19 en général et notamment le thème de
la santé
la parole est à monsieur olivier marc
l'ex merci monsieur monsieur le
président je prends les ministres dans
un crise que nous traversons je voudrais
au nom des députés
les républicains prendre évidemment et
comme notre solidarité et notre
compassion à toutes les victimes du coc
vie de 19
il ya leurs familles je vais aussi
évidemment ils prennent une pensée
particulière pour la mémoire de nos
collègues patrick devedjian et jean
françois cesarini la semaine dernière
encore ma collègue virginie duby muller
au nom des républicains exprimer notre
incompréhension et regrettait l'absence
d'une politique de dépistage massif dans
notre pays
le dépistage à une triple vertus qui
permet d'isoler d'identifier pardon
d'abord les malades de les isoler par
rapport à leurs familles de protéger
l'entourage et de ne pas attendre enfin
déco pic des complications éventuelles
les pays qui ont la plus forte a pu
faire
la plus faible mortalité monsieur le
premier ministre sont les pays que ce
soit l'asie du sud-est ou en europe
nos voisins allemands qui teste
massivement vous avez annoncé il ya
quelques jours un virage un changement
de cap
nous nous en réjouissons mais nous
comprenons toujours pas votre stratégie
vous annoncez que vous des pistes
auraient massivement mais pour
l'essentiel en sortie de confinement
c'est à dire que lorsque la pandémie
sera pour l'essentiel derrière vous nous
parlez d'un objectif de 100 mille tests
par jour mais pour le mois de juin
d'ici là on passerait quand même de 5000
tests réalisés par semaine actuellement
à 20 mille tests par semaine dès la
semaine prochaine
vous en conviendrez ce n'est pas encore
à la hauteur du besoin dans notre pierre
à ma question est très simple qui va
profiter de ce surcroît de tests
supplémentaires
êtes vous prêt à concentrer l'effort sur
les établissements pour personnes âgées
les personnes âgées sont les plus
vulnérables les plus fragiles face à ce
virus et l'enfermement en chambre dans
les étables dans les ehpad n'est pas une
solution qui pourra durer bien longtemps
n'attendons pas l'hécatombe quelle
politique de dépistage systématique
monsieur le premier ministre êtes vous
prêt à mettre en place pour les soigner
les plus tôt possible
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur olivier ferrand ministre des
solidarités et de la santé merci
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues
mesdames et messieurs les députés pardon
monsieur le député marc l'ex vous posez
la question des tests je vais peut être
renouvelée des explications que nous
avons pu fournir à la nation samedi
dernier lors d'une conférence de presse
tout d'abord vous dire que il ya trois
méthodes de test une méthode de test dit
par pcr qui est la méthode qui est sûr
que nous exerçons en france comme dans
le l'ensemble des pays du monde le font
sur leur territoire une technique qui
est lourde qui passe par des plateformes
pc rdp retourne technologique
nous en avons acheté de nouvelles qui
sont répartis aux quatre coins du
territoire national dans les antilles
évidemment incluse et ces tests pcr
monte en puissance nous sommes désormais
au dessus de 20 mille tests réalisable
par jour et nous serons à 50 mille tests
jour d'ici la fin du mois d'avril comme
l'épidémie progresse qui est de plus en
plus de nouveaux malades et notamment
des soignants malades des personnes
fragiles malades des personnes
hospitalisées malades
ou des personnes en ehpad ou des gens
qui travaillent en ehpad qui peuvent
être potentiellement malades ou fragiles
et et à protéger
l'augmentation de ce nombre de test
permet de dépister systématiquement
toutes ces personnes et ces publics
prioritaires
par ailleurs nous avons expliqué que
nous passons des commandes et nous avons
passé des commandes pour des nouveaux
tests
quand je dis nouveau c'est que il n'y a
pas un pays qui applique ces politiques
de dépistage par test rapide depuis des
jours et des jours ce sont des tests
nouveau qui relève de l'innovation de la
recherche et du développement que nous
avons acheté nous pouvons fournir aux
français à raison de 30 milles par jour
dès le mois d'avril et nous augmenterons
progressivement jusqu'à cent mille tests
jours dc dc des deux prochains mois et
enfin le troisième volet de ces méthodes
de dépistage
c'est le volet des sérologies ça c'est
très important ce qui permettra par une
prise de sang ou un prélèvement de sang
de déterminer si quelqu'un a été malade
en contact avec le virus et si donc il
est immunisée contre le virus et donc si
je peux me permettre l'expression s'il
est tranquille vis-à-vis de cette
maladie et je vous dis que les soignants
qui travaillait en ehpad sont des
publics absolument prioritaire pour
dépister le virus que ce soit par pcr ou
par texto rapide même si monsieur le
ministre
la parole est à monsieur philippe michel
railpower pour la question douala michel
de vos couleurs
monsieur le président par délégation de
patrick mignola président du groupe
modem et apparentés il me revient de
poser au ministre de la santé des
solidarités la question de la collègue
michel de vaucouleurs député des
yvelines à laquelle vous me permettrez
d'y associer justine bénin d'ateliers
limaces brahim hammouche cyrille isaac
sybille et bruno myle yens tous membres
de la commission des affaires sociales
la situation et venait d'en parler
monsieur le ministre la situation
sanitaire particulièrement préoccupante
dans les ehpad
alors nous nous réunissons doit nous
amener à repenser profondément la prise
en charge la dépendance en structures
mais aussi à domicile
ce dossier mobilise depuis le début de
la mandature notre assemblée impatiente
à ce titre de se remettre au travail
afin de donner corps à une prise en
charge plus satisfaisante de nos aînés
au moment nous parlons alors que les
personnels soignants et administratifs
des ehpad se démène nous
la prise en charge à domicile est mise
elle aussi en difficulté en raison de
nombreux arrêts maladie des personnes
aidantes à domicile dans ce contexte il
apparaît à mes collègues de la
commission des affaires sociales
opportun d'anticiper la publication du
décret d'application du congé proches
aidants mesures prescrites par l'article
45 de la loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2020 qui prévoit
une indemnisation du congé pour le
proche aidant
car rappelons le c'est près de 11
millions de français soit un sur six qui
sont aujourd'hui des aidants régulier
mais non professionnels qui soutiennent
un proche en perte d'autonomie ainsi
vous comprenez l'intérêt que porte mes
collègues de la commission à ce que les
aidants qui le souhaitent puissent le
plus vite possible se consacrer
pleinement à l'accomplissement l
accompagnement pardon d'un proche aussi
monsieur le ministre
le décret d'application de cette mesure
est prévue d'ici octobre 2020 ne
serait-il pas une mesure de justice
sociale que d'avancer la mise en
application d'une telle mesure
merci merci chers collègues la parole
monsieur olivier ferrand ministre des
solidarités de la santé merci monsieur
le président monsieur le député vous
m'interrogez sur la situation
particulière des aidants pendant
l'épidémie et je vous en remercie parce
que la question des aidants est une
question primordiale et ça me donne
l'occasion de peut-être faire le point
d'abord vous dire ce que sur la question
du congé proches aidants c'est une
avancée majeure du dernier budget de la
sécurité sociale
je mets tout en oeuvre pour que nous
puissions prendre un tel décret dans les
meilleurs délais pour qu'ils puissent
être appliquées au plus tôt possible
j'entends votre sollicitation et j'y
suis extrêmement sensible vous dire
également que les aidants parce qu'ils
prennent soin des personnes les plus
fragiles au quotidien font partie des
cadres exceptionnels dérogatoires qui
leur permet à la fois de circuler pour
aller voir leurs proches malades en
situation de handicap ou en perte
d'autonomie
c'est une exception à l'interdiction de
déplacement et une exception aussi
importante au fait que les personnes
âgées doivent rester chez elle confiné
et le plus éloigné possible d autres
personnes elles ne peuvent pas faire
sans leurs aidants il était normal que
la nation le reconnaissent
par tous les moyens au delà la question
des personnes fragiles en ehpad dont
j'ai un peu parlé tout à l'heure il ya
aussi la question du handicap et
notamment des enfants en situation de
handicap un certain nombre de structures
sont fermés mais les services doivent
rester disponibles pour les parents qui
en ont besoin
même à distance même par téléphone ou en
visio vous dire que j'avais confié j'ai
confié une mission à jérôme guedj ancien
parlementaire sur la question
particulière du prendre soin des
personnes âgées fragiles à domicile
elles sont plus d'un million trois cent
mille personnes âgées concernées
il me rends nous travaillons en fait au
jour le jour pour promouvoir des
dispositifs il en existe et je remercie
les élus locaux pour leur engagement
sans faille au quotidien qui par
l'action des ccas par l'action des
tissus associatifs des collectivités
territoriales prennent des nouvelles
appellent contact et permet de prendre
soin des personnes lorsqu'elles sont
isolés je remercie aussi la croix rouge
des ong des associations avec lequel
nous travaillons ainsi que christelle du
boss secrétaire d'état en charge des
personnes âgées et sur la question du
handicap je ferai une communication très
prochainement avec sophie cluzel
secrétaire d'état auprès des personnes
en situation de handicap pour que nous
méritions aussi promouvoir des solutions
innovantes de solidarité dans la période
merci monsieur le ministre la parole à
madame la présidente valérie rabault
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre face à la crise due
qu'aux gros navires us mon groupe que
j'ai l'honneur de représenter
aujourd'hui m'a transmise nombreuses
questions et je vais en aborder deux
la première porte sur la réanimation
vous avez annoncé samedi dernier vouloir
augmenter la capacité de notre pays à
14000 places contre dix mille
actuellement et 5000 initialement et je
vous en remercie
au-delà de cette annonce se pose la
question des stocks de médicaments qui
sont utilisés en réanimation et en
particulier les curares le curare 6 atra
curium ou encore le mid à lausanne
hypnotique qui sont des anesthésiques
pouvez vous monsieur le premier ministre
oui ou non me confirmer que la france
dispose de stocks suffisants pour faire
fonctionner ces quatorze mille places de
réanimation et si oui sur quel horizon
de temps par ailleurs se pose également
la question de la post réanimation qui
est nécessaire pour tous les patients
qui ont subi une réanimation demain
hier aiguë et je souhaiterais sur ce
point monsieur le premier ministre que
vous puissiez nous indiquer le nombre de
places disponibles
ma deuxième question portera sur les
outre mer vous savez des premiers cas de
coronavirus sont apparus et la situation
va être très compliqué de fait déjà la
situation insulaire du fait des carences
des hôpitaux sur place du fait de la
difficulté à maintenir du confinement
quand les températures avoisinent d'ores
et déjà 30 degrés comme cela est le cas
et du fait du manque de masques à ce
sujet monsieur le premier ministre à la
réunion par exemple la ministre a
indiqué hier que le quota de 420 mille
masques prévu pour lille était déjà reçu
via de commandes
pourtant les professionnels de santé
continue d'alerter sur le manque de
matériel de protection je cite l'exemple
de la réunion
mais c'est partout aussi ailleurs le cas
aussi je souhaiterais que vous puissiez
m'indiquer quelles exactement le stock
de masques et de tests dans les outre
mer dont les pas les habitants vont
pouvoir bénéficier je vous en remercie
merci mme la présidente la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la
présidente vous poser beaucoup de
questions et demandé beaucoup de
chiffres vous m'avez adressé un courrier
il ya encore peu de temps avec je crois
près de 25 questions précises qui sont
posées c'est parfaitement légitimé et
vous vous doutez bien madame la
présidente que j'essaierai d'apporter
toutes les réponses le plus précisément
possible dans cette période où nos
concitoyens sont en attente légitime de
réponse précise
j'essaie de répondre le plus précisément
possible et quand je n'ai pas le chiffre
de tête
vous demandez le stock de masques dans
tel ou tel département alors dans ce cas
je préfère vous renvoyer à une réponse
plus complète par écrit ou à l'occasion
d'une prochaine rencontre
mais je veux quand même répondre aux 2
questions vous poser la première et je
vais commencer par là la seconde je
terminerai par la première la première
question à laquelle vous ne répondrez la
question des outre-mer vous l'avez dit
l'insularité l'exception de la guyane
mais l'insularité est un sujet qui est
à prendre en compte dans l'organisation
des soins nous connaissons la fragilité
sanitaire de ces territoires n'est pas
neuve elle est ancienne elle est parfois
contrecarré par des projets
d'investissements massifs vous
connaissez comme moi le projet plus
exactement la construction actuellement
de l'hôpital en guadeloupe d'un nouvel
hôpital très résilient très performant
il n'est pas encore achevée et donc nous
savons la situation sanitaire délicate
c'est d'ailleurs parce que nous savons
la situation sanitaire délicate que nous
avons pris des mesures s'agissant des
territoires ultramarins en avance de
phase par rapport à la situation
épidémique
nous avons confiné l'ensemble des
territoires ultramarins alors même que
dans un certain nombre d'entre eux le
virus ne circulait pas en situation dite
épidémique qu'on était encore dans ce
qu'on appelle parfois le stade 1 ou le
stade pourquoi parce que évidemment il
faut ralentir encore plus la circulation
du virus dans ces territoires
compte tenu de la fragilité sanitaires
et dans le même temps où nous prenions
ces mesures quarantaine à l'arrivée sur
le garden 14/n à l'arrivée sur le sur le
territoire limitation stricte des motifs
qui permettent d'arriver sur les
territoires confinement généralisée
possibilité pour les préfets de prendre
des mesures de couvre-feu
comme nous l'avions indiqué dans le
cadre national mais nous avons incité
les préfets sur ces territoires à
utiliser ces mesures si elles étaient
nécessaires
lorsqu'elle était nécessaire nous avons
parallèlement choisi d'augmenter la
capacité d'accueil hospitalière des
territoires autant que cela nous était
possible et j'ai eu l'occasion
d'indiquer samedi je ne peux pas vous
redonnez précisément ici l'ensemble des
chiffres mais que dans tous les
territoires mayotte réunion anti bien
entendu dans tous les territoires nous
allions augmenter la capacité d'accueil
en réanimation pour faire en sorte que
nous puissions apporter une réponse qui
quoi qu'il arrive ce sera une réponse
délicate à une situation délicate là je
ne veux pas je veux dire les choses
clairement
c'est aussi la raison pour laquelle nous
avons décidé de projeter des moyens y
compris des moyens militaires pour
pouvoir soulager les territoires dans
leur capacité d'accueil de lit en
réanimation pour m'interroger c'était le
la première partie de votre question sur
la question des médicaments
nous avons des stocks les établissements
des stocks stock national de ces
médicaments bien entendu mais là encore
je veux dire les choses clairement
partout dans le monde ça n'est pas
propre à la france vous le savez
parfaitement partout dans le monde
la consommation des médicaments liés à
la réanimation est en train d'exploser
parce que le nombre de réanimation
explose littéralement
si en france nous sommes passés de 5000
lits à plus de dix mille lits si dans le
même temps d exercice comparable dans
des proportions parfois différentes mais
comparables ont été menées en italie en
espagne sont en train d'être menée au
royaume uni sont en train d'être menée
aux états unis partout dans le monde
alors évidemment la consommation des
molécules nécessaires à la réanimation
placement en réanimation maintien
réanimation cette consommation explose
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
mis en place un plan national qui
consiste à avoir des approvisionnements
nationaux de façon à pouvoir regrouper
les commandes et à pouvoir utiliser à la
fois la force de commandes groupées et
l' influence de la diplomatie française
lorsque l'approvisionnement de ces
médicaments n'est pas strictement
nationale nous avons mis en place cette
méthode nous avons mis en place une
méthode qui vise à répartir ces fonds en
fonction des besoins dans les régions
pour veiller à ce que chacun puisse
avoir l'accès aux molécules nécessaires
c'est un exercice qui est un exercice
difficile nous avons pris des mesures
elles peuvent vous sembler enfin elles
peuvent sembler accessoires ou minimes
elles sont en réalité très importante
nous avons par exemple fait en sorte
qu'une décision soit prise dans l'union
européenne pour que les médicaments
produits dans le territoire de l'union
européenne ou à l'extérieur de l'union
européenne puisse arriver sous une seule
forme d'emballage ça peut donner mais
pourquoi est-ce que vous c'est à dire
avec des emballages notamment écrit dans
une seule langue en anglais
nous l'avons fait parce que le simple
fait de permettre cette dérogation à une
règle qui normalement ne peut pas
prévaloir sur le territoire national a
permis à certaines visites d'augmenter
par trois leur production de se
concentrer sur la production du produit
et pas sur les spécificités propres à
chaque pays
en faisant cela nous augmentons la
capacité à nous doter de médicaments et
de partout ces moyens là nous veillons à
faire en sorte que les huit molécules
essentielles
mathieu intéressante lévy molécules
essentielles soient bien approvisionné
mais je ne cache rien des difficultés
qui pourraient intervenir non pas à
court terme et probablement pas non plus
à moyen terme
mais dans la durée
si l'industrie pharmaceutique de son
côté n'augmente pas considérablement ses
capacités de production parce que aucune
consommation résiste à une augmentation
de 2000% durablement et donc c'est
évidemment l'enjeu essentiel de cette de
ce combat qui est un combat collectif et
que nous avons menées avec l'ensemble de
nos partenaires
merci monsieur le premier ministre la
parole est à madame frédérique dumas
merci monsieur le président mes pensées
vont d'abord vers la famille de patrick
devedjian et de jean-françois ces arrêts
ni ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
premier ministre
vendredi dernier vous avez annoncé le
prolongement du confinement de la
population jusqu'au 15 avril prochain en
précisant qu'elle ait deux semaines à
venir serait encore plus difficile
le comité scientifique sur lequel vous
dites vous appuyez avait préconisé six
semaines pourquoi ces annonces de
périodes successives de quinze jours qui
ne permettent pas d'anticiper de se
préparer qui crée de la confusion
par ailleurs nous le savons le
confinement ne sera efficace que si nous
donnons effectivement les moyens de
protéger ce qui nous protège à la
pénurie de masques s'ajoute celle des
surblouse des respirateurs mais aussi
des test dit pcr qui permettrait
d'éviter les contaminations notamment en
milieu hospitalier
au delà des milliards qu'on nous annonce
vouloir investir les annonces concrètes
concernant leurs disponibilités sont
systématiquement en décalage avec la
réalité
pouvez-vous nous assurer que les
personnels soignants seront suffisamment
équipées en matériel et qu'ils seront
testés que les forces de l'ordre seront
protégés pour assurer le confinement que
nous aurons la capacité d'équiper
correctement les pompiers les
ambulanciers les personnels des ehpad
les aides à domicile tous ceux qui sont
envoyés en première ligne et tous ceux
qui continuent à travailler pour le bien
de tous peut-on disposer de calendrier
fiables et précis sont l'ensemble des
matériels ainsi que sur leur répartition
enfin quelle est votre stratégie précise
pour affronter les semaines à venir
le déconfinement ne sera possible qu'en
identifiant les personnes immunisées
contre le coc vie de 19 ce qui nécessite
de développer au plus vite les tests de
sérologie quand seront ils prêts et pour
quelle utilisation
au-delà des mesures immédiates urgente
de protection que vous devez aux
français pouvez vous nous donner des
perspectives nous éclairer sur votre
stratégie de crise et de sortie de crise
dont on sait qu'elle ne pourra qu être
progressive
vous devez au français d'expliquer non
seulement le comment mais aussi le
pourquoi de vos décisions
je vous remercie merci mme la députée la
parole monsieur olivier ferrand
ministre des solidarités et de la santé
madame la députée frédérique dumas il ya
beaucoup de questions dans votre
question
j'entends la question principale qui
porte sur la stratégie de protection et
sur la stratégie de de gestion de
l'épidémie ou de lutte contre l'épidémie
le mot est plus exact de lutte que de
gestion en l'occurrence d'abord vous
dire qu'il ya une étude intéressante
keane étude anglaise qui est paru hier
soir assez tard par l'impérial college
london et qui s'interroge sur l'effet du
confinement
ça fait partie des questions que me pose
est est-ce que le confinement ça
fonctionne nous on a dit que ça
fonctionnait la france a pris très tôt
des mesures de confinement généralisée
et nous avons eu l'occasion plusieurs
fois nous dire que c'était le seul moyen
de freiner la diffusion d'un virus dès
lors que vous nous ne maîtrisons pas ce
virus en lui-même parce que faute de
vaccins développés à ce stade l'effet du
confinement il est majeur d'après cette
étude anglaise dont je n'ai pas de
raison de douter même si je ne la prends
pas pour argent comptant
elle tend à montrer qu'en douze jours de
confinement ce sont 2500 vie qui ont
déjà été épargnée de notre pays c'est à
dire que toutes les 8 minutes
nous serons une vie en restant chez nous
et ce nombre va augmenter jour après
jour à mesure que le confinement portera
ses fruits et fera ses effets nous
lèverons le confinement lorsqu'il ne
sera plus nécessaire lorsque la
circulation active du virus aura cessé
et lorsque les hôpitaux qui sont en
lutte dans le grand est dans l'île de
france en bourgogne franche comté en
corse et dans bien d'autres coins du
territoire national lorsque ces hôpitaux
auront réussi à faire face à la vague de
patients sévère de patients graves qui
remplissent des réanimations et qui
mobilisent des milliers des centaines de
milliers de soignants et d'acteurs de la
protection nationale au quotidien nous
leur devons la protection vous l'avez
dit nous l'avons dit cette protection
albas entre autres par des masques
nous avons fait toute la lumière sur les
commandes je peux même vous les donner à
date d'aujourd'hui ce sont 1 milliard
700 millions de masques qui ont été
commandés en france et à l'étranger et
qui vont arriver progressivement des
arrivées se font quasi quotidiennes par
avion
elles sont que de la part de l'industrie
française et présent de la république a
eu l'occasion de dire ce matin que d'ici
la fin de l'année la france sera
désormais autonome dans la durée pour sa
propre production de masques merci
monsieur le ministre nous un député
monsieur le ministre je vous ai
justement d'en demander pourquoi vous
aviez annoncé 15 jours alors que le
comité scientifique demandé six semaines
donc je n'ai pas remis en cause le
confinement bien au contraire
et la deuxième chose après je vous ai
dit effectivement après comment on peut
mettre les décisions d'aujourd'hui en
perspective avec les décisions pour
demain merci madame la députée la parole
et à madame mathilde pas non monsieur le
premier ministre
dans mon hôpital nous avons trois jours
de stocks d'anesthésiques on doit
choisir les patients admis dans notre
service en fonction de leur probabilité
de s'en sortir mais si on en venait à ne
plus soigner ou à mal soignée ceux qui
peuvent s'en sortir
ce serait vraiment terrible voici la
souffrance insupportable des soignants
il manque de tout de masques de lits de
personnel de respirateurs de test est
maintenant de médicaments de curare
indispensable pour relaxer les muscles
lors d'un tube à sion de patients de
sédatifs pour les personnes en
réanimation de morphine d'antibiotiques
une catastrophe dans la catastrophe
le manque de médicaments c'est
l'impossibilité de mettre sous
respirateur toutes les personnes qu'ils
le devraient
c'est des gens qui vont mourir
d'étouffement à cause de douleurs alors
qu'on aurait pu les sauver
on ne parle pas de semaine pour une
rupture totale de certains de ses
médicaments
mais deux jours vous demandez déjà aux
hospitaliers de limiter l'usagé de la
morphine
la pénurie est déjà là vous avez été
alertée la semaine dernière par le
président de la commission médicale des
hôpitaux de paris par l'observatoire de
la transparence dans les politiques du
médicament sans réponse votre gestion de
crise monsieur le premier ministre c'est
une gestion de la pénurie
vous avez affirmé lors de votre
conférence de presse dès que nous aurons
le sentiment que la réquisition est
nécessaire il sera procédé à des
réquisitions
n'avez-vous toujours pas le sentiment de
l'urgence nous avons en france le savoir
faire qu'attendez vous pour
réquisitionner les moyens de production
pour fournir ces médicaments
indispensables
qu'attendez vous pour nationaliser
luxfer dernières usines en europe à
produire des bouteilles d'oxygène
médical ou famars qui fabrique 12
médicaments d'intérêt thérapeutique
majeur chaque heure compte pour prendre
ses décisions vie
tall coordonner la production
réquisitionner les entreprises
nécessaire impliquer les travailleurs
concernés
c'est ce que nous appelons la
planification sanitaire nous en sommes
là aujourd'hui parce que la loi du
marché a eu le dernier mot
il y a trente ans 80% des médicaments
était produit en europe
aujourd'hui c'est 20% organiser le
retour de l'état monsieur le premier
ministre
nationaliser réquisitionnés ou bien
laissez nous faire sans quoi vous aurez
des comptes à rendre
celui d'un naufrage merci mon nom a
débuté la parole de monsieur olivier
ferrand ministre des solidarités et de
la santé madame la députée panneaux
d'abord je tiens à corriger quelque
chose la liste pourrait être longue
il ya une chose que je corrige
immédiatement il n'y a aucune demande de
limitation des limitations de recours à
la morphine auprès de qui que ce soit la
morphine madame panneaux vous dit vous
avez exigé de la part des soignants qui
limite le recours à la morphine
je le dis comme ministre de la santé et
des solidarités et avec gravité parce
que ce n'est pas une information qu'on
peut manipuler comme ça pour faire un
effet de tribune
il n'y a aucune demande de limitation de
médicaments permettant de lutter contre
la douleur contre les patients je le dis
maintenant il y à des tensions sur les
stocks de produits anesthésiques
il ya des tensions sur l'utilisation
d'un certain nombre de produits dans des
hôpitaux
il y a le premier ministre l'a expliqué
il ya quelques minutes un stock
stratégique national permettant de faire
des commandes massives et de gestion
rigoureuse territorialisée en fonction
des besoins exprimés par les
établissements de santé et par les
médecins libéraux portant sur huit
molécules d'intérêt majeur le premier
ministre a également expliqué qu'il ya
parfois une consommation qui a explosé
de l'ordre de 2000 % pour certains
médicaments par en france dans le monde
aux états unis dans toute l'europe dans
l'asie en afrique partout et donc quand
vous avez tous les pays qu'ils
recherchent les mêmes produits au même
moment les capacités de production tombe
évidemment mise en tension en france
comme ailleurs de manière à pouvoir
apporter toutes les réponses mais à
mesure que l'épidémie augmente à mesure
que le nombre de malades s'accumulent
dans les hôpitaux et les réanimations
cela met en tension
tous les systèmes productifs et tous les
systèmes de soins du monde entier
vouloir faire croire que ce soit que ce
serait un problème franco français
n'aiment pas
je crois n'est pas à la hauteur de
l'enjeu et pour autant je n'ai jamais
nier et je ne dirai jamais les
difficultés lorsqu'elles existent et
elles peuvent exister et c'est pourquoi
nous prenons toutes les décisions la
réquisition sur les masques le 3 mars la
france a été le seul pays en europe à le
faire le seul pays en europe à le faire
et le président de la république était
ce matin pour annoncer que 10000
respirateur ont été commandés auprès de
l'ensemble des industries productif de
notre pays qui sont capables en l'espace
de quelques jours de réorienter leurs
capacités productives pour fournir du
matériel de protection et des moyens de
soigner les gens c'est ça l'image de la
france madame panneau je crois que nous
pouvons aussi renvoyés dans cet
hémicycle
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à madame l info sion merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse au
ministre de la santé l'organisation
mondiale de la santé n'a cessé depuis le
début de l'épidémie d'appeler tous les
pays touchés à multiplier les dépistages
pour chaque cas symptomatiques son
directeur a encore rappelé hier à genève
qu'il avait un message simple pour tous
les pays tester tester tester les gens
alors il ya nos voisins allemands qui
réalise désormais un demi million de
tests de dépistage par semaine la france
ne réalisait encore la semaine dernière
que 5000 par jour vous avez semblé
samedi dernier vouloir opérer un
changement de stratégie en annonçant la
commande massive de tests sérologiques
dans l'espoir de pouvoir pratiquer
quelques cent mille tests par jour d'ici
la fin du mois de juin
nous notons cette inflexion stratégique
mais de nombreuses questions persistent
qu'est ce qui justifie d'abord que notre
pays n'est pas dès le départ pris la
décision de suivre ces recommandations
de l'om s en matière de dépistage
cette question en appelle une autre sur
la stratégie sanitaire de sortie du
confinement de la population puisque
vous avez parlé de fin juin pour la
question du dépistage massif nos
concitoyens aspirent à une information
claire sur la stratégie poursuivie ces
perspectives et les projections qui sont
les vôtres
aujourd'hui les citoyens respectent dans
leur grande majorité
le confinement il faut le souligner
apporter notre solidarité ils ont
d'autant plus besoin d'être éclairé sur
la méthodologie attendez-vous d'avoir le
nombre de tests de dépistage nécessaires
pour entamer la stratégie
la sortie du confinement votre objectif
est il encore d'atteindre le seuil de
l'immunité de groupes en vous assurant
d'ici là de minimiser le nombre de
victimes
la sortie sera t-elle progressive est
fonction de la disponibilité de la
disponibilité des masques pour le grand
public va-t-on manquer de médicaments
autant de questions sur lesquelles nous
aimerions vous entendre monsieur le
ministre je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur olivier ferrand ministre des
solidarités et de la santé madame
faucillon je vous remercie pour votre
question elle pose question sur la
stratégie
enfin votre question porte sur la
stratégie globale que nous menons et
comment est ce qu'elle est amenée à
évoluer elle pose un enjeu essentiel que
vous avez cités c'est celui de
l'immunisation de la population
c'est-à-dire à partir de quelle
proportion de français immunisés contre
le virus c'est-à-dire ou vacciner quand
les vaccins existent ou déjà confrontés
à un virus de façon symptomatique ou non
à partir de quelle proportion de la
population
on peut considérer que le virus aura
terminé de circuler
comment faire en sorte que cette
circulation soit le plus frais n'est
possible de manière à permettre à nos
hôpitaux de sony les malades et vous
voyez aujourd'hui avec le grand est et
l'ile-de-france notamment ô combien il
était vital de d'appeler au confinement
généralisée pour éviter qu'il y ait un
afflux malade encore plus important dans
les hôpitaux et qui aurait complètement
emporté notre système de santé et vous
poser la question de savoir comment sont
assurés comment s'assurer du niveau
d'immunisation la population c'est tout
l'enjeu de la sérologie la sérologie qui
est pair capable de déterminer si on a
développé des anticorps des
immunoglobulines en réaction à
l'exposition au virus
en l'absence de vaccin mais j'espère de
tout coeur et vous aussi chacun ici que
nos industriels sanofi ou d'autres
seront capables de développer très
rapidement mais si c'est important aussi
de saluer l'industrie pharmaceutique
vous savez parce que on a une très forte
industrie pharmaceutique qui est très
mobilisé et moi je leur tire mon chapeau
parce qu'ils sont avec nous et que les
salariés sont au boulot du soir au matin
pour faire de la recherche et produire
des médicaments
il faut aussi le reconnaître en période
d'épidémie est donc comment est-ce qu'on
comment est-ce qu'on s'assure du taux
d'immunisation c7 sérologie qui est en
cours en encore en cours de recherche et
de développement
aucun pays au monde n'a encore réussi à
à établir élaborer une sérologie
diffusable à grande échelle mais la
recherche progresse très vite et j'ai
très bon espoir que dans quelques jours
peut-être dans quelques semaines au plus
tard nous puissions réaliser des
sérologies en population alors nous
verrons quel est le pourcentage de
population qui est immunisée contre le
virus et ce sera un indicateur
extrêmement précieux pour savoir comment
piloter les politiques sanitaires à
l'égard du virus une fois que nous
aurons level confinement cela et toute
la politique de tests que j'ai eu
l'occasion d'aborder il ya quelques
minutes en réponse un de vos collègues
merci monsieur le ministre la parole
c'est à madame charlotte le poc qui
porte les questions de ses collègues du
groupe la république en marche la parole
merci monsieur le président permettez
moi tout d'abord d'adressé de la part de
tous les membres du groupe la république
en marche un message de condoléances à
la famille et aux proches de notre
regretté collègue jean-françois ces
araignées ma question s'adresse c'est la
question de michel aux annales s'adresse
à monsieur le ministre des solidarités
et de la santé monsieur le ministre la
pandémie de kobe 19 que nous traversons
actuellement
mais notre système de santé à rude
épreuve michel lausanne a souhaité
rappeler ici tout son soutien aux
personnels de santé qui luttent chaque
jour pour sauver des vies et à toute la
chaîne de santé des secrétaires aux
ambulanciers il tient aussi à saluer les
personnels de l'état et des
collectivités territoriales qui assure
les besoins du quotidien et plus
largement à tous ceux qui travaillent
sauver des vies c'est dans les cas les
plus graves placer le patient en
réanimation
pour ce faire nous avons besoin de
médicament anesthésique puissant tel que
le que rare
de nombreux professionnels s'alarme
d'une réduction inquiétante des stocks
dans les hôpitaux dans sa
circonscription du lot et garonne une
usine ips a implanté à aja produits
différentes formes de paracétamol le
député lausanne ah tiens avant tout à
saluer le travail des salariés qui
oeuvrent sans relâche à la production de
médicaments
si une production française de
médicaments perdure malheureusement la
matière première elle est importée de
chine ou des états unis
cette crise nous interroge donc sur
notre stratégie industrielle
pharmaceutique et le besoin de
relocaliser la production et la matière
première en valorisant par exemple le
made in france
c'est donc aussi la politique tarifaire
et ses impacts qui est questionnée
monsieur le ministre nous
taton la france a besoin d'une nouvelle
politique industrielle pharmaceutique
notamment pour protéger ces sites
stratégiques aussi le député michel
losana souhaite que vous nous indiquez
les pistes envisagées par le
gouvernement en ce sens au regard de la
production des stocks disponibles de
médicaments le risque de pénurie est il
à ce jour totalement écartée
merci madame la députée la parole et à
monsieur olivier ferrand ministre des
solidarités et de la santé madame la
députée en période d'épidémie face à un
virus inconnu dire qu'il n'y a aucun
risque de quoi que ce soit serait allé
au-delà de ce que je peux vous répondre
décemment en conscience considérant les
données de la science en france et dans
le monde
il ya des éléments que nous connaissons
qui ont déjà été abordés au cours de
cette séance de questions à savoir que
la demande de certains médicaments
explose dans le monde de l'ordre de
2000% que ça crée des situations de
tension parfois des situations de manque
ou en tout cas de réduction des stocks
qui nous oblige en permanence à faire
preuve d'une logistique accéléré
réactive pour faire en sorte qu'aucun
hôpital ne manque en définitive de
possibilité de soigner les malades c'est
le cas dans le monde entier je
m'entretiens avec mes homologues
européens mais également américains ou
japonais dans le cadre du g7 santé vous
avez raison et votre collègue michel
lausanne a raison de souligner que cela
pose une question majeure celle de
l'indépendance de la france et de
l'europe en matière de production de
matériaux de produits vitaux essentiels
et c'est une réflexion que nous avions
déjà commencé à amorcer et comme député
vous le vous le savez puisque nous avons
adopté déjà un certain nombre de
dispositions dans le dernier budget de
la sécurité sociale par exemple une
disposition qui contraint les
laboratoires pharmaceutiques à conserver
sur le territoire national ou européen
l'équivalent de quatre mois de stock
pour tout ce qui est médicalement
d'intérêt thérapeutique majeur au delà
face à la crise sanitaire parce que nous
aurons l'occasion de reparler de ces
sujets essentiels réindustrialisation
j'ai eu l'occasion de saluer d'ailleurs
les industries pharmaceutiques en france
extrêmement mobilisés pour répondre à la
demande et je lire salue à nouveau parce
qu'elles le méritent
il y à une priorisation au niveau
régional par les ars de la répartition
des stocks de médicaments indispensables
dans la période
nous renforçons les approvisionnements
par un sourcing accrue en lien avec l'
agence du médicament et nous régulons
plus strictement les stocks présents sur
le territoire comme sur le modèle des
respirateurs enfin partout c'est
nécessaire nous identifions avec les
soignants avec les blouses blanches des
alternatives pour certains médicaments
s'ils venaient à manquer demain parce
qu'encore une fois face à une épidémie
nous devons être modeste mais nous
devons être armés et nous devons tout
faire pour être en mesure de lutter avec
efficacité
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à monsieur olivier marc l'ex qui portent
des questions des députés du groupe
l'est républicain
si monsieur le président ma chemise de
la santé vous commencez à apporter
quelques remèdes à la criante pénurie de
masques chirurgicaux et ffp2 dont la
france souffre toujours et souffrira
encore longtemps une pénurie qui semble
être le pilier de notre stratégie face
aux cages vides 19 ou de la sono façon
dont souffre aujourd'hui les personnels
soignants est compris dans les grands
hôpitaux mais aussi les libéraux les
infirmières les paramédicaux tous les
intervenants à domicile tous ceux à qui
nous rendons évidemment un vibrant
hommage
c'est désormais aussi du manque de tous
les autres matériels de protection les
sur blues mais charlotte les gants les
gels hydro alcooliques mais aussi de
tensions sur les réserves et
l'approvisionnement de médicaments comme
les antibiotiques le curare ou encore la
morphine
il a un risque à la fois de pertes de
change pour certains malades et de
carences dans l'accompagnement digne des
patients en fin de vie
et là chacun semble être renvoyée au
système d on assiste certes de très
belle opération de solidarité mais
probablement que cet enjeu de santé
publique appellerait une réponse mieux
coordonnés par l'état le collectif un
terreau pitot vous a demandé hier de
procéder à des réquisitions
vous avez vous même évoqué le stock
stratégique national mais pouvez-vous
nous préciser s'il vous permettra de
tenir ou non jusqu'à la fin de la crise
nous sommes probablement encore que dans
une phase montante
quelles initiatives d'urgence allez-vous
prendre face à ces nombreux
manque dont souffrent des personnels
merci monsieur le député d'abord le tas
monsieur olivier ferrand ministre des
solidarités et de la santé monsieur le
député je vais profiter de votre
question j'ai beaucoup répandu sur la la
question des masques et ça ne veut pas
dire que ça apporte une réponse concrète
à ceux qui les attendent
mais je crois que nous avons exprimé à
la fois les difficultés auxquelles nous
faisons face et surtout les difficultés
auxquelles font face
en conséquence les soignants sur notre
territoire vous dire que 40 millions de
masques ont été stockés pour les
hôpitaux les ehpad les aides à domicile
et soins en médecine de ville
je pourrais aussi inciter d'autres
acteurs de première ligne comme les
pompiers les éducateurs spécialisés les
les acteurs qui travaillent dans
l'hébergement d'urgence
le premier ministre a eu l'occasion
d'exprimer le fait que la production
française était orientée vers des
masques de protection destinés aux noms
soignante qui avec des personnes qui
agissent sur le territoire et nous
continuons d'avoir une régulation du
déstockage de masques en fonction de nos
capacités à le faire et en fonction des
besoins exprimés sur les territoires à
mesure que ces masques arrivent sur le
territoire national je les 10,1
milliards 700 millions de commandes ont
été passées en france et à l'étranger
des masques nous arrive très
régulièrement
ça ne suffit pas encore pour pouvoir
voir suffisamment loin pour augmenter le
déstockage mais ça fait partie
au delà de ça il ya la question des
blouses des surblouse la question des
gants la question des charlottes pour
lequel nous passons également des
commandes tous azimuts dans tous les
pays qui en produisent avec à nouveau la
même difficulté sans attendre que la
question ne soit posée je vous rassure
ça fait ça fait des semaines que c'est
le cas avec à nouveau la même difficulté
qui nous n'avons pas si ça fait des
semaines que c'est le cas mais c'est le
député ça fait avec la avec à nouveau la
même difficulté que celle que nous
rencontrons sur les masques à savoir que
le monde entier fait face à des
difficultés poser la question aux
voisins allemands voisins italiens
voisins espagnols anglais hollandais
belges suisses tout le monde recherche
les mêmes matériaux au même moment ces
matériaux qui sont massivement fabriqué
dans un pays la chine qui était percutée
par l'épidémie des mois avant nous les
usines se sont arrêtés avant même que
les usines et reprises on a passé toutes
les commandes possibles à l'étranger
pour être les premiers pour pouvoir
mieux armer nos soignants mieux les
accompagner 100 élèves rien la
difficulté
vécue au quotidien par nos soignants que
je remercie encore pour leur engagement
sans faille mais ça apporte une
explication à la situation à laquelle
nous faisons face et surtout ça explique
la stratégie qui consiste à dire nous
dit stockons mais nous devons voir loin
pouvoir protéger dans la durée merci
monsieur mais ce monsieur le député ce
ministre sur les masques je vais donner
acte effectivement dit quelque chose
avait changé avait été prise en prison
pris en main en revanche tous les autres
matériels les choses ne semblent pas
encore de protection qui ne veut pas
encore arrivés notamment les dans l'est
dans les hôpitaux ou auprès des autres
personnels libéraux infirmiers etc et rs
n'ont pas de réponses très concrètement
abordé sur notre territoire
c'est ça le centre de ma question merci
monsieur le député la parole et kavala
mathilde de panneaux qui porte les
questions du groupe la france a sonné
monsieur le premier ministre vous avez
décidé la prolongation du confinement
pour 15 jours
dont acte les français sont respectueux
des consignes dans un moment de péril
sanitaire les inégalités elles ne sont
pas confinés quatre millions de
personnes sont mal logées 1,3 million
vivent dans des logements indignes
pour eux le confinement force et c'est
la prison le confinement c'est aussi
l'explosion des violences
intrafamiliales que subissent
essentiellement les femmes et les
enfants dès le début de ce moment
exceptionnel
nous avions des craintes vis-à-vis de
vos prises de décision nous espérions
être démentie vous les avez confirmé en
effet l'aveuglément capitaliste qui vous
a toujours guidé lui n'est pas confinée
après nous avoir refusé le
rétablissement fussent temporaire de
l'impôt de solidarité sur la fortune
voilà votre ministre des comptes publics
en train de faire la manche et de
réinventer les impôts sous forme de
cagnotte en ligne à lire le contenu de
vos ordonnances qui attaquent le droit
du travail et des libertés fondamentales
on se demande ce que vous faites plutôt
que de préparer la sortie du confinement
ne seriez vous pas en train de poser les
jalons d'un nouveau choc néolibérale
notre inquiétude grandit monsieur le
premier ministre
avez-vous pensé lapray préparez-vous le
long processus qui va s'ouvrir celui du
déconfinement pour cela pas d'autre
solution que de tester et ce de manière
massive toute la population et il faut
d'ores et déjà le faire maintenant pour
toutes les personnes qui travaillent
combien de tess manque t-il quelles sont
nos capacités de production pourquoi
refusez-vous l'aide des laboratoires
vétérinaires qui vous la propose depuis
semaine et pourraient produire des
centaines de milliers de tests il nous
faudra confiner les malades séparément
quelles sont les capacités d'hébergement
disponibles autant de questions sans
réponse
le monde d'après se bâtit maintenant la
bifurcation et commencer sur d'autres
bases avec d'autres principes d'autres
moyens
les maux du monde d'après son simple
souveraineté populaire planification
réquisitions vous asséner que vous ne
laisserai personne dire qu'il ya eu du
retard sur les mesures de confinement
nous le disons oui il y a eu du retard à
l'allumage
et si rien est anticipée nous vous
dirons bientôt et les millions de
français avec nous qu'il y a eu du
retard sur les mesures de déconfinement
la parole est un monsieur olivier véran
ministre des solidarités et de la santé
je suis désolé madame panneaux j'ai pas
compris le sens général de votre
question je à la fin je veux sincèrement
est-ce que vous souhaitez que nous des
confignon plutôt le pays
mais pour des raisons est que ne je n'ai
pas compris je vous assure j'ai essayé
de comprendre je n'ai pas compris je
vais peut-être vous répondre sur une
partie de la question que j'ai compris
vous parliez des publics les plus
fragiles c'est une question qui me
touche comme ministre des solidarités de
la santé qui touche notre majorité le
gouvernement et l'ensemble des français
et vous me donnez peut-être l'occasion
de préciser un certain nombre de
dispositions qui ont été prises on va
parler du cac 40 même panneau on va
parler des gens qui sont fragiles qui
sont précaires et qui sont parfois
percuter encore plus durement par une
épidémie comme celle du coronavirus pour
des conditions de logement précaire pour
des conditions d'isolement ou de revenus
qui sont extrêmement faibles vous dire
que nous avons prolongé le bénéfice des
minima sociaux sans condition pour les
bénéficiaires sur une durée allongée de
temps de voir venir la fin d'épidémie
afin que personne ne se retrouve privé
du rsa privé de la hache privé de toutes
les allocations sociales vous dire
également que nous avons prolongé la
trêve hivernale qui devait s'arrêter le
31 mars au 31 mai ce qui offre une
protéine garanties de protection pour
des gens qui sont sans abri par exemple
ou qui sont dans des hébergements
précaires ou en difficulté pour payer
leur loyer vous dire également que nous
travaillons avec julien de normandie
d'arrache-pied à toutes les solutions
qui permettent d'augmenter les
hébergements d'urgence destiné au public
précaire précarisés qui sont dans la rue
qu'il soit sdf qu'il soit migrants
ou qu'il n'est tout simplement pas de
domicile dessin pour pouvoir vivre et
passer cette crise dans des conditions
décentes et digne vous dire que je
travaille et que nous travaillons en
lien avec l'ensemble des ong la croix
rouge médecins du monde médecins sans
frontières et des associations qui
viennent en aide aux publics fragiles
aux personnes isolées qui font preuve
d'innovation dans la solidarité dont
personne ne doutait mais qui se révèlent
en plus redoutablement efficace dans la
période et que les services de l'état
les remercie et sont allés à leurs côtés
pour mener avec elle ce combat qui je le
dis n'a rien de politique qui a tout du
main merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à monsieur ludovic pajot
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
en cette période d'état d'urgence
sanitaire de nombreux français sont
légitimement inquiet inquiet de voir
chaque jour le nombre de contaminations
augmenté et de nouveaux décès inquiet du
risque d'engorgement de nos services de
soins intensifs et de réanimation le
risque touche désormais l'épuisement
même des stocks de produits nécessaires
à la réanimation
qu'il s'agisse de respirateurs de curare
et même de bouteilles d'oxygène
l'initiative d'air liquide de se lancer
dans la fabrication de respirateurs
avant même toute demande officielle est
salutaire mais révélatrice de l'absence
d' état stratège et de souveraineté
nationale
inquiet quant aux masques au manque de
masques équipements pour nos soignants
qui sont en première ligne en secteur
hospitalier
en médecine de ville sans oublier les
infirmières libérales mais il ne faut
pas oublier aussi les aides à domicile
les policiers gendarmes salariés du
transport du commerce des pompes
funèbres et bien d'autres secteurs
stratégiques
l'exigence de 200 millions de masques
par mois n'est pas en mesure d'être
respecté face à cette situation les
responsables politiques doivent la
transparence aux français mais aussi
être visionnaire les experts de l oms
s'accordent pour dire qu'une des clés de
la réussite face à cette épidémie et la
généralisation des tests
al'inverse de la france l'allemagne et
la corée du sud ont très rapidement
multiplié les tests et isoler les
malades
notre pays est en retard aussi dans ce
domaine alors monsieur le ministre
peut-on espérer avoir dans les prochains
jours
les premiers résultats des essais
cliniques actuellement en cours type
discovery et pouvez vous nous confirmer
qu en cas d'identification d'une
molécule efficace pour combattre le
virus
les stocks seront prêts pour
approvisionner les établissements de
soins dans les meilleurs délais c'est un
élément indispensable pour la sortie du
confinement
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
député la parole est à monsieur olivier
ferrand ministre des solidarités et de
la santé
monsieur le député pajot vous comparez
la france avec d'autres pays en termes
de stratégie de test vous auriez pu
comparer la france avec d'autres pays en
termes de mise en oeuvre du confinement
là vous verriez que la france a été
écrit ici c'est si très très en avance
par rapport à l'ensemble des pays nous
avons même d'ailleurs impulser une
dynamique européenne est un site est
très fortement des pays qui étaient en
retrait par rapport à ces politiques de
confinement à nous enjoint de le faire
vous auriez pu suivre les interventions
des membres du gouvernement lors des
différentes commissions européennes lors
des différents conseils européens à son
public d'ailleurs vous auriez vu que la
france a été avec l'allemagne avec
l'italie l'espagne et un ou deux autres
pays les premiers pays au sein de
l'union européenne a dit la menace
épidémique était réelle et qu'il fallait
que l'europe se prépare et s'arme je
crois que comparer l'un et l'autre il
faut le faire dans sa globalité moi je
salue ce que vous avez cité l'allemagne
le voisin allemand qui nous aide
énormément dans la période qui nous
prêtent du matériel qui est capable de
transférer des malades de la région
grand est vers son territoire national
et qui permet de soulager les
réanimations cette solidarité européenne
à laquelle nous croyons énormément et
qui fait la beauté de l'europe et qui
fait la beauté de l'europe qui fait
aussi son harmonie et qui fait que nous
sommes attachés à cet idéal européen
puisque cette europe
elle fonctionne en plein monsieur le
député elle fonctionne en plein et si
nous n'avions pas l'europe aujourd'hui
nous n'aurions pas ce soutien très fort
de l'allemagne et nous ne serions pas en
mesure de tendre la main à nos voisins
espagnols avec même un hôpital en commun
qui est du côté de la catalogne
côté français et nous n'aurions pas les
moyens de tendre la main à nos voisins
italiens qui sont dans la difficulté
j'étais à rome deux jours après
l'émergence des premiers malades en
italie pour tendre la main à nos voisins
européens
toute cette solidarité là je tiens à
vous le dire parce que j'en profite
européenne elle nous aide et elle sauve
des vies aujourd'hui ensuite vous dire
que nous n'avons pas attendu votre
intervention pour demander à air liquide
de travailler ça fait des semaines et
des semaines et des semaines
posez la question aux industriels
demandez-leur à quel moment nous avons
les avons contactés il ya quelques mois
ils ont répondu favorablement pour
produire des masques pour produire des
respirateurs pour produire des solutions
hydro alcooliques pour produire des
médicaments appelé les acteurs
industriels vous verrez vous diront que
nous n'avons pas attendu que vous
réveillez monsieur députés pour leur
demander de l'aide et de se mettre en
fonctionnement pour le pays et pour les
soignants merci monsieur le ministre
nous poursuivons maintenant notre séance
avec des questions portant sur des
thèmes économiques et sociaux
la parole de monsieur olivier marc l'ex
ce premier ministre madame la ministre
vous le savez tous les secteurs
économiques toutes les activités toutes
les entreprises sont touchées par par la
crise
ils ont entendu avec espoir les
propositions du président de la
république mais dans la réalité avec
tous mes collègues des groupes du groupe
l'est républicain
mais j'en suis persuadé sur sur tous les
bancs nous sommes interpellés au
quotidien par des chefs d'entreprise qui
nous disent que c'est dans la réalité
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué que ça sur
l'aide du fonds de solidarité
je salue votre volonté de l'étendre pour
le mois d'avril aux entreprises qui ont
perdu 50 % de leur chiffre d'affaires et
non plus 70% si une demande constante
que les députés de mon groupe te ment et
eric woerth une véronique louwagie
nicolas forissier avait porté en
commission mais vous devez également
évidemment appliquer cette règle au mois
de mars faire autrement n'aurait aucun
sens à titre d'exemple aussi c'est une
comparaison je promise qui est assez
cruel pour notre pays je voudrais quand
même rappeler que l'allemagne
l'allemagne mais 50 milliards d'euros
dead sur la table en aide directe pour
les entreprises 50 milliards nous
mettons 1,2 milliard c'est à dire 40
fois moins d'argent sur la table
ce serait bien de ne pas trop en
rajouter en tracasseries administratives
sur le chômage partiel par exemple
beaucoup de dossiers ne sont pas refuser
mais sont invalidés contestée par les
directement pour des histoires parfois
je tue pic de numéro siret ce qui ne
fonctionne pas et puis les injonctions
contradictoires de l'état continue de
mettre certaines entreprises en
situation impossible
on doit rester ouvert mais les clients
n'ont pas droit de de sortir certains
dispositifs sont également mal calibré
j'ai en tête l'exemple des restaurateurs
qui font des contrats de travail à 40
heures mais qui ne peuvent être
indemnisés que sur la base de 35 heures
donc ça leur pose évidemment un problème
et puis dans certains secteurs la
réponse de l'état n'est pas à la hauteur
je pense à des acteurs du tourisme qui
sont vraiment menacé de faillite en
cascade aux horticulteurs et
pépiniéristes dans les pertes de
chiffres d'affaires seront ré timide
rédhibitoire monsieur le premier
ministre
pouvez vous nous dire à l'heure où la
précision et la crédibilité de la parole
publique sont plus importantes que je
mène nous expliquer précisément comment
vous comptez corriger les
dysfonctionnements du dispositif actuel
sur merci merci monsieur le député la
parole à madame agnès pannier rue nash
et secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre
de l'économie et des finances merci
beaucoup monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député maire l'ex le
dispositif que nous mettons en oeuvre
pour accompagner les entreprises c'est
un dispositif massif c'est un dispositif
qui répondent à des centaines de
milliers d'entreprises c'est un
dispositif qui est immédiatement
opérationnel parlons du fond de
solidarité
le fonds de solidarité cela a été dit
ces 1500 euros qui seront versés dans
les premiers jours d'avril par les dr
philippe c'est à dire les services
fiscaux de manière quasi automatique aux
très petites entreprises qui font valoir
une baisse de 50% leur chiffre
d'affaires au mois de mars n'a été
précisé ce matin par bruno le maire
s'est également les entreprises qui ont
dû fermer fermeture administrative
les choses sont donc très simple et
gérald darmanin s'est engagé à ce que
ces dossiers soient traités de manière
extrêmement rapide
c'est un dispositif de chômage partiel
qui est extrêmement efficace également
et qui n'a pas d'égal au niveau européen
je veux leur rappeler c'est plus de 8
milliards d'euros qui sont mobilisés
pour les entreprises c'est des règles
qui sont accessibles sur le site du
travail travail.gouv.fr alors certes des
centaines de milliers d'entreprises sont
aujourd'hui en train de demander leurs
numéros mais elles ont 30 jours et c'est
à effet rétroactif donc elles ne doivent
pas s'inquiéter quant aux règles elles
sont très simples si la convention
collective prévoit plus de 35 heures
le chômage partiel s'applique aux
horaires prévus par la colère convention
collective
si ces 39 heures ça sera sur 39 heures
les choses sont très claires
en revanche pas de chômage partiel pour
les heures supplémentaires
je crois qu'il n'y a pas de difficulté
dans la compréhension de ce dispositif
enfin c'est également un soutien à
l'économie massif au travers des 300
milliards d'euros de garanties bancaires
au travers également parce que nous
apprenons des crises précédentes des 10
milliards d'euros de garanties apportés
aux assureurs crédits et des 2 milliards
de garanties apportées aux assureurs
export un dispositif donc très complet
merci madame la ministre
un parole est à monsieur philippe michel
costes bauer pour monsieur mary merci
monsieur président est tout d'abord
permettez moi de dire que le groupe
modem s'est associé aux condoléances que
vous avez présenté à la famille de notre
collègue jean-françois cesarini la peine
et la douleur qui le partagent monsieur
le président cette question préparée par
mon collègue vincent bru député des
pyrénées-atlantiques s'adresse à madame
agnès pannier rue nash et secrétaire
d'état auprès de monsieur le ministre de
l'économie et ils sont associés erwan
balanant isabelle florennes
elodie jacquet laforge philippe la tombe
et laurence vichnievsky
madame la ministre est avant tout propos
mon groupe voudrais saluer le
remarquable travail en ces temps
difficiles accompli par votre
administration à destination de nos
entrepreneurs de nos salariés de nos
commerçants et de nos indépendant mais
mon collègue vincent bru s'est attelé à
vérifier sur le terrain
l'évaluation de la participation des
compagnies d'assurances à l'effort de la
lutte dans la lutte contre les effets de
la pandémie à cet effort de guerre que
le gouvernement conduite par monsieur le
premier ministre s'efforce de mener avec
bienveillance
après plusieurs échanges avec l'union
des métiers et des industries hôtelières
par la voix de son président roland
héguy avec les présidents des chambres
consulaires la fédération départementale
du btp des pyrénées atlantiques avec de
nombreux commerçants il est apparu que
très nombreux étaient ceux qui s'étaient
entendus répondre
une non compensation par les compagnies
d'assurances des pertes d'exploitation
liées à l'épidémie
nous sommes tous concerné sur nos
territoires et là le montant des 200
millions d'euros abondés par la
fédération française des assurances au
fonds de solidarité paraît assez faible
au regard de ses capacités réelles jeu
par comparaison n'est pas raison mais
nous avons vu dans d'autres moments de
générosité des montants bien plus
supérieur à celui ci arrivait vite au
devant de la scène et comme les aimait
professeurs sur les bulletins de notes
peut mieux faire ainsi madame la
ministre nous vous demandons d'insister
auprès de la fédération française
d'assurance à participer davantage à cet
effort de guerre
ensuite nous vous proposons de modifier
après cette crise bien entendu le code
des assurances faucon afin d'intégrer au
même titre que des catastrophes
naturelles les catastrophes sanitaires
madame la ministre il vous plait
délivrez nous votre avis sur ces deux
propositions merci monsieur débuté la
parole est à madame agnès venir une
hache et secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'économie et des finances
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
brute vous avez raison dans ce moment
particulier chacun chacun entreprises
particuliers industriels doit participer
à cet effort de guerre et cet effort de
lutte contre cette crise sanitaire et
c'est ce que nous attendons du secteur
des assurances
alors évidemment reconnaître aujourd'hui
l'état de catastrophe naturelle n'aurait
qu'une portée modeste puisque la moitié
seulement des entreprises sont prémunis
dans leurs contrats d'assurance contre
la perte d'exploitation et vous imaginez
bien que ce sont souvent les plus
structurées les plus grosses et donc pas
nécessairement celles qui en ont le plus
besoin c'est pour ça nous avons que nous
avons demandé aux entreprises d
assurances de d'apporter une
contribution au fonds de solidarité
fonds de solidarité qui lui est dirigée
vers les très petites entreprises celles
qui en nous aujourd'hui
réellement besoin c'est pour ça aussi
que dans le sens que vous indiquez nous
continuons à travailler avec le secteur
des assurances pour qu'elle continue à
assurer de très petites entreprises qui
ne seraient pas à date en capacité de
payer leur contribution à leur contrat
parce que rien ne serait plus délicat
qui en perdent le bénéfice de cette
assurance alors même qu'elles sont en
difficulté se seraient assurés des
difficultés a ajouté des difficultés à
des difficultés et c'est dans cet esprit
que nous continuions à avancer avec le
secteur des assurances
effectivement en essayant de le rendre
le plus contributif possible à la fois
dans le traitement des dossiers
individuels des entreprises mais
également dans leur engagement au profit
de la collectivité
je vous remercie merci madame la
ministre
la parole est à mme la présidente
valérie rabault oui merci monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
ma seconde question porte sur les
aspects économiques pour lesquels mon
groupe a formulé plusieurs propositions
et je vais vous en avez repris certes
avec un peu de retard mais notamment
pour l'extension du fonds des des tpe ou
encore la suppression du jour de carence
pour les fonctionnaires je souhaite donc
vous soumettre trois propositions très
concrètes monsieur le premier ministre
sur les assurances ça a été dit
précédemment beaucoup de commerces des
indépendants des artisans souscrit une
assurance perte d'exploitation en cas de
reconnaissance de la catastrophe
naturelle l'assurance leur compense une
partie du chiffre d'affaires qui n'ont
pas pu réaliser mais pour beaucoup
d'entre eux beaucoup d'entre eux se sont
vu refuser cette compensation au motif
que dans le contrat qu'ils ont signé
lille a une clause qui stipule qu'en cas
de pandémie
les assureurs n'ont rien à payer même si
l'état de catastrophe naturelle était
reconnue en 2018 les assureurs ont
encaissé deux virgules milhas 2,1
milliards d'euros de cotisations au
titre de l'assurance perte
d'exploitation monsieur le premier
ministre
êtes vous oui ou non favorable à faire
contribuer les assureurs sur le modèle
de la contribution spéciale temporaire
que vous aviez créé pour toutes les
entreprises en décembre 2017
cela permettrait de rapporter de l'ordre
de 1,4
derouin deuxième proposition de nom bleu
fleuron français ont vu leur valeur
boursière s'effondrer ces derniers jours
ce qui signifie qu'ils sont des proies
faciles pour les investisseurs étrangers
il est indispensable de les protéger des
prédateurs aujourd'hui la loi permet aux
ministres de l'économie de refuser des
investissements étrangers mais cela ne
vaut que pour quelques secteurs
êtes vous monsieur le premier ministre
oui ou non favorable à ce que nous
étendions ce régime d'autorisation
préalable à toutes les sociétés cotées
en bourse aux achats brevets et ce
jusqu'à la fin de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
ceci permettrait à votre ministre de
l'économie de pouvoir contrôler tous les
rachats voire de les interdire les états
unis le font déjà
troisième proposition en matière de
versement dividende votre ministre de
l'économie a appelé les entreprises
aidées par l'état ne pas distribuer de
dividendes
nous proposons inscrire dans la loi
seriez vous d'accord avec cette
proposition
oui ou non je vous remercie merci mr le
président
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre vous fait encore la présidente
beaucoup de questions de votre question
3 cette fois ci sur la question des
dividendes nous avons appelé en effet à
la modération
les entreprises qui souhaitent verser
des dividendes et nous avons posé un
principe qui je crois est simple lorsque
les entreprises font appel à la
possibilité qui leur est offerte de
reporter leurs charges ou lorsqu'elles
font appel à la garantie de l'état dans
les emprunts qu'elle contracte auprès
des banques
c'est à dire au fond quand on le fonds
appelle à la solidarité de l'état sur
les directs et financière de l'état pour
leur permettre de tenir alors nous
considérons qu'elles ne peuvent pas
distribuer de dividendes c'est la règle
telle qu'elle a été formulée
s'agissant des entreprises qui ont
recours au chômage partiel nous avons
encouragé et aidé par non je parle des
grandes entreprises
car quand on parle des entreprises on
parle bien d'une entité juridique mais
en vérité vous savez très bien que l'on
ne parle pas de la même chose
la sarl de 12 salariés dont bien souvent
le patron se paye en dividendes beaucoup
plus qu'en salaire ne peut pas être de
ce point de vue me semble-t-il regarder
exactement comme la multinationale non
mais je sais que vous vous êtes d'accord
avec moi sur ce point là je le dis parce
que il peut arriver que notre échange
soit retransmis
je veux bien précisé que lorsque je
parle des entreprises sur l'interdiction
qui est faite c'est pour les grandes
entreprises
s'agissant du recours au chômage partiel
donc à l'activité partielle nous avons
invité les entreprises à faire preuve de
modération
car là encore nous devons veiller à ce
que la stabilité y compris la stabilité
actionnariale des entreprises soient
garantis il faut donc qu'elle soit en
mesure d'apprécier ce qu'elles peuvent
faire ou ne pas faire mais nous avons
fermement invité à la modération et nous
pensons que le message est entendu sur
la vigilance sur des investissements
étrangers
nous sommes effectivement vigilant et
vous avez raison de nous y inviter car
nous ne voudrions pas que des
entreprises qui participent de la
souveraineté nationale qui ont une place
particulière dans le tissu économique
productif puisse être à l'occasion de la
diminution de leur valeur boursière la
cible d'investisseurs étrangers qui
auraient conservé des capacités
d'investissements considérables et qui
viendrait prendre le contrôle sur les
entreprises vous savez parfaitement
qu'il existe des dispositions qui nous
permettent de veiller à ce que les
entreprises qui relèvent de la
souveraineté nationale ne soit pas
l'objet de tels raids s compte
évidemment mise en oeuvre nous avons
également indiqué que nous étions prêts
lorsque cela nous paraissait nécessaire
soit de prendre nos responsabilités dans
les entreprises où l'état est déjà
actionnaire
lesquels peuvent d'ailleurs ça peut
arriver qu'il y ait des règles sur des
entreprises dans lesquelles l'état est
déjà actionnaire soit le cas échéant
d'aller jusqu'à des prises de contrôle
nous n'avons fermé aucune possibilité en
la matière mais évidemment nous ne
pouvons pas d histoire peut-être de
certains annonçaient que nous allons
prendre le contrôle de toutes les
entreprises et et j'ai bien compris que
ce n'était pas votre proposition et que
c'est à dire pas votre votre idée
s'agissant de l'interdiction de principe
qui serait posée il nous paraît que
l'interdiction de principe qui serait
posée pourrait avoir plus
d'inconvénients que d'avantagés
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
n'avons pas décidé une interdiction de
principe avec une autorisation qui
serait l'exception mais il n'en reste
pas moins que la vigilance à laquelle
vous nous invitez est réelle et que nous
allons veiller
à ne pas placer des entreprises
françaises dans des situations où elles
seraient fragilisés enfin vous évoquer
la question de la participation des
assureurs à l'effort collectif
un mot d'abord pour dire que les
assureurs ont accepté de participer à
hauteur de 200 millions d'euros au
financement du fonds de solidarité qui a
été proposé et créée par le gouvernement
les régions elle même accepté de
participer à hauteur de 250 millions
d'euros à ce fonds n'a donc été
augmentée de 1 milliard initiale à 1
milliard 2 et il est probable nous
l'avons dit qu'il sera tenu de
fonctionner pour le mois d'avril
également et peut-être pour la suite car
par une incidente à des questions qui
ont déjà été posés nous savons
parfaitement que le travail sur la
période de déconfinement est un travail
qui est devant nous il a déjà été
engagée au niveau technique au niveau
sanitaire au niveau économique mais les
conditions dans lesquelles nous allons
pouvoir d confiné sont encore à l'étude
et dépendent très largement de
l'efficacité du confinement de la
capacité d'accueil dans les services de
réanimation
puisque je renvoie à la stratégie
globale qui est la nôtre nous voulons
veiller à ce que le virus ne circule pas
à un rythme tel qu'il déborderait les
capacités nationales d'accueil dans les
services de réanimation dès lors le
déconfinement devra prendre en compte la
réalité de la diminution des cas
d'entrée en réanimation c'est donc une
question délicate délicate du point de
vue technique du point de vue sanitaire
du point de vue économique du point de
vue politique bien entendu aucun aucun
d'entre nous ici
quelles que soient ses orientations
politiques ne souhaitent que le
confinement dure trop longtemps
aucun d'entre nous ne souhaite qu'il
soit durable nous voulons tous le
limiter à la plus simple de son
expression à la plus rapide de son
expression mais personne n'accepterait
non plus je le dis à ceux qui
s'interrogent sur la période de
confinement personne n'accepterait non
plus que le déconfinement se traduise
immédiatement parce qu'il n'aurait pas
été accompagnée d'une bonne politique de
test parce qu'il n'aurait pas été
accompagnée du
une politique de préparation par une
augmentation immédiate renouvelée du
nombre de cas sévères qui devraient être
accueillis dans les hôpitaux c'est donc
une réflexion qui est en cours nous
aurons l'occasion d'en parler en ce
moment ce sont des experts qui
travaillent sont des équipes qui
travaillent pour voir comment est-ce
qu'on peut réfléchir les équipes
sanitaires
comment est-ce qu'on peut avancer sur le
déconfinement et bien entendu nous
répondrons le moment venu à toutes les
questions en la matière les assureurs
pour revenir à notre sujet sont appelés
à participer à cet effort
vous évoquez la question d'une
modification par la loi du sens de
contrats qui sont passés entre personnes
privées
bah si par définition si dans les
contrats il est prévu que en cas de
pandémie il n'y a pas de que les
pandémies ne faut ne relève pas des
circonstances liées à l'état de
catastrophe naturelle
si on veut le faire en sorte qu'il n'en
soit pas ainsi il faut bien que la loi
interviennent à l'intérieur de contrat
entre personnes privées ce n'est pas
impossible mais vous le savez c'est très
strictement limitée par la jurisprudence
du conseil constitutionnel
de même qui est très strictement limitée
par la jurisprudence du conseil concerne
la possibilité de faire participer
certaines entreprises sur des critères
qui ne serait pas objectifs par rapport
au regard du but recherché au
financement de la protection sociale
et c'est d'ailleurs un élément qui avait
conduit le gouvernement lorsqu'il avait
dû lorsqu'il avait dû tirer les
conséquences de pratiques antérieures
qui avait été déclarée
anticonstitutionnelle madame la
présidente vous en souvenez sans doute
je sais bien que c'est à ça que vous
faites référence plus que c'est nous qui
avons dû trouver la solution qui a
permis de rembourser
nous avions dû viser une catégorie
générale des entreprises au delà d'un
chiffre d'affaires est pas une catégorie
particulière d'entreprise en fonction de
leur objet et donc si nous voulons
travailler sur cette hypothèse
il faut évidemment vérifier qu'elle soit
conforme à la jurisprudence du concile
du conseil constitutionnel laquelle est
extrêmement exigeante en la matière je
sais que vous le savez mais là encore il
me paraît utile de pouvoir le rappeler
merci monsieur le premier ministre
la parole est à monsieur thierry benoit
pour le groupe udi agir et indépendant
merci monsieur le président permettez
moi tout d'abord au nom des députés du
groupe u10 agir et indépendant
de m'incliner de saluer la mémoire de
patrick devedjian de jean-françois
cesarini et de l'ensemble des victimes
du coronavirus puisque dans cette partie
des séances des questions au
gouvernement nous sommes dans la partie
économique et financière je veux revenir
sur deux acteurs incontournables même si
madame la ministre vous avez répondu de
manière complète sur la question de
perte d'exploitation est naturellement
monsieur le premier ministre l'instant
je voudrais dire tout d'abord parce que
nous remontons ici les revendications ou
le sentiment qui nous viennent du
terrain
moi depuis la bretagne où je viens et
bien sûr les mesures que vous avez
prises jusqu'à présent concernant les
mesures économiques elles sont bien
appréciés elles sont elles reçoivent un
accueil favorable de la part des acteurs
économiques qu'ils soient artisans
commerçants industriels indépendants
il subsiste cependant à juste titre des
interrogations et des inquiétudes
première interrogation et première
inquiétude premier sujet les banques
est il possible au delà de toutes les
mesures que vous avez prises afin
d'apporter de la sérénité à nos
concitoyens dans cette période de crise
que ce soit les entreprises où que ce
soit les particuliers est-ce que nous
pouvons demander aux banques à ce qu'il
n'y ait pas de pénalités et d'intérêts
complémentaires pour tous demande de
report d'échéances de prêt prêt pour
entreprise ou prêts pour un particulier
prêt pour une maison demande de report
de trois modes de six mois ça peut être
quelque chose qui se présente à nous
s'il ya cette cette précaution de prise
et enfin pour les pertes d'exploitation
il y a urgence je fait écho à ce qui
vient d'être dit par les deux collègues
députés précédent il y a urgence à
travailler avec les banques avec des
banques assurances avec les assureurs à
ce que l'état de catastrophe naturelle
dans un cas de force majeure comme celui
que nous vivons soit étendue à état de
catastrophe naturelle et sanitaires
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
madame agnès pannier rue nash et
secrétaire d'état auprès du
str de l'économie et des finances merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
benoist merci beaucoup de souligner la
qualité du plan qui a été effectivement
construit construit par les services de
l'état mais construit aussi avec l'appui
des collectivités locales je veux
remercier ici les régions qui apportent
leur contribution au plan s'agissant du
fonds de solidarité et qui vont la bonne
l'abonder de manière importante et qui
apporte des dispositifs complémentaires
je veux également revenir sur la
question des assurances puisqu'elle a
été posée par plusieurs personnes sur
ces bancs et particulièrement sur l'état
de catastrophe naturelle ce qui
aujourd'hui pose problème sur le fait de
prononcer à date un état de catastrophe
naturelle vous l'avez compris c'est que
ce n'est pas un risque contre lequel
l'ensemble des assurés est assurée c'est
un risque contre lequel on peut choisir
ou pas de ne pas être assurés à la
différence de la catastrophe naturelle
où chacun dans nos polices d'assurance
nous avons de manière obligatoire
cette protection et c'est ce qui a
permis de construire une protection pour
l'ensemble des français lorsqu'il est
exposé un état de catastrophe naturelle
avec un fond de réassurance qui est
abondée régulièrement et qui permet de
venir servir les personnes qui ont été
confrontées à ces situations
cette situation nous amène à évoluer et
à considérer que dans la presse il
faudra probablement effectivement mettre
en place une réflexion sur la
reconnaissance d'un état de catastrophe
sanitaire et qu'il faut construire la
même chose que ce qui a été fait pour
les catastrophes naturelles est d'ores
et déjà nous avons entamé la discussion
avec avec les assurances s'agissant des
banques maintenant et des reports je
crois qu'il faut distinguer la situation
des particuliers les particuliers
aujourd'hui sont assez protégé au
travers du chômage partiel et au travers
des dispositifs que nous mettons pour
les indépendants en tout cas c'est là le
sens de notre action
en revanche et les entreprises que nous
devons protéger aujourd'hui c'est pour
ça que l'action en direction des banques
va dans ce sens parce que les
entreprises
pour beaucoup d'entre elles chiffre
d'affaires et donc ne peuvent pas faire
face à leurs dépenses je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre la parole est à
madame frédérique dumas pour le groupe
liberté territoire merci merci monsieur
le président ma question s'adresse
madame at any time bardon agnès pannier
rue nash et c'est la question de
l'ensemble des députés de mon groupe
libertaire et territoires du fait de la
situation je voulais le rappeler face
aux répercussions économiques de la
crise actuelle nous avons voté un
soutien massif aux entreprises en vous
donnant des prérogatives étendues
mais aujourd'hui les modalités
d'application interroge qui a réalisé un
écart entre les annonces fortes et la
réalité du terrain
certains secteurs font face souvent
seule à cette terrible injonctions
contradictoires entre reprise du travail
est impératif d'assurer la sécurité des
salariés
l'intervention de la minus de travail
sur la responsabilité des entrepreneurs
alors que les équipements de protection
manque ajouté confusion à incertitudes
avec le btp il ya eu des maladresses les
premiers jours puis les organisations et
gouvernements ont enfin échanger autour
d'un guide de reprise des chantiers
promis la semaine dernière il est très
attendu
qu'en sera-t-il publiées et combien
d'autres guides de bonnes pratiques sont
prévues concernant le chômage partiel
des entreprises nous remontent encore
aujourd'hui malgré vos déclarations des
cas de refus je pense aux experts
comptables notaires ou encore aux
ostéopathe le fonds de solidarité
suscite d'autres questions que se
passera-t-il si le nombre d'entreprises
éligibles dépasse les 400 mille prévus
allez vous augmenter l'enveloppé ou
durcir les critères faudra-t-il compter
sur la seule générosité des français
pour une ré la hanche comme le ministre
des comptes publics l'a dit ce matin
cette question vous le comprenez est
cruciale suite aux nombreuses demandes
dont les nôtres le seuil d'éligibilité a
été abaissé à 50 50 pour cent de perte
du chiffre d'affaires c'est très bien
pour avril est finalement aussi pour
mars
et pourquoi ne pas calculer la baisse
d'activité à partir du confinement de 15
mars dans keinon à partir du 1er mars
aujourd'hui 31 mars nos entreprises les
plus petites font face à leurs échéances
à l'urgence elles ont besoin d'être
rassurés pouvez-vous nous apporter des
réponses concrètes à toutes ces
questions je vous remercie
merci mme le député la parole est à mme
agnès pannier une hache et secrétaires
d'état
auprès du ministre de l'économie et des
finances merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés à
madame la députée dumas la réalité du
terrain nous en prenons la mesure tous
les jours en animant l'ensemble du
direct en ayant le contact avec les
entreprises en animant les crp qui sont
au contact des entreprises en difficulté
et en faisant en sorte qu'aucune de ces
entreprises ne se trouve sans réponse
alors très concrètement s'agissant de la
reprise du travail s'agissant la reprise
du travail le ministère du travail
c'est un travail de recommandations
branche par branche filière par filière
que j'ai moi même entamé avec les
filières industrielles nous en avons 18
mai ce travail et les faits aussi au
niveau des routiers au niveau des du btp
au niveau de la grande distribution et
de toutes les professions que nous
accompagnons je veux signaler d'ailleurs
ici le travail remarquable de lui et
même qui a pris et à accompagner ses
propres entreprises et qui a commis un
guide de référence qui peut être utilisé
très largement par d'autres entreprises
et effectivement renvoyé au travail de
muriel pénicaud et laurent piètre à skis
qui branche par branche filière par
filière élabore ses recommandations et
qui sont à la disposition des
professionnels pour s'assurer que les
mesures de distanciation et les gestes
anti barrière soit mis en place
quelles que soient les situations de
travail parce que vous l'avez compris
notre priorité est que les salariés
puissent prendre le travail comme nous
le faisons aujourd'hui en parfaite
sécurité
ça c'est le premier point le guide du
btp il est prêt il faut encore finaliser
la question des équipements nous y
répondons c'est exactement le sens de ce
qui a été fait qui permet aujourd'hui de
fournir des équipements individuels de
type masque qui ne sont pas
nécessairement nécessaire pour faire les
mesures de distanciation et les gestes
andy barr hier mais qui sont demandés
par beaucoup de salariés donc nous
sommes à leur écoute et qui sont
aujourd'hui disponibles dans un certain
nombre d'entreprises et je rappelle que
ces équipements ils sont lavables ça
veut dire que vous pouvez les réutiliser
donc un million par jour de masques
produits c'est probablement cinq à dix
millions d'équipements disponibles pour
les professionnels merci madame la
ministre
la parole est à madame isaf sion
pour le groupe de la gauche démocrate et
républicaine merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre des responsables
associatifs syndicaux demandent au
gouvernement de prendre une ordonnance
empêchant toutes les grandes entreprises
de verser des dividendes rachats
d'actions et bonus au pdg en 2020 les
députés de mon groupe soutiennent cette
démarche
monsieur le maire a invité les
entreprises à faire preuve de civisme et
de modération ça a le mérite de pointer
un scandale mais il croyait vous vous
même ces entreprises vont bénéficier de
mesures d'urgence une partie de leurs
salariés vont toucher seulement 84 % de
leur salaire il serait incompréhensible
que les entreprises qui bénéficient de
ces mesures d'urgence continuent de
verser des dividendes record d'un compte
et d'un côté le conseil des ministres
présente des ordonnances prête à limiter
les droits des travailleurs faisant
supporter aux plus modestes le coup de
la récession économique de l'autre
monsieur le maire appelle à un nouveau
capitalisme plus soucieux lutter contre
les inégalités
d'autres l'ont déjà fait disant vouloir
moraliser le capitalisme
c'est oublier que sa voracité c'est son
moteur aux multinationales c'est donc la
leçon de morale aux travailleurs ce sont
les sacrifices gravé dans la loi celles
et ceux qui exercent les missions les
plus essentiels vitales sont aussi les
moins bien rémunérés je pense aux
soignants aux caissières fonctionnaires
agriculteurs agriculture triste
chauffeur assistantes maternelles jean
pla j'en passe ils ne réclament pas un
monument juste leur dû justice dignité
égalité les grandes entreprises ont
toutes retrouvées aujourd'hui le niveau
de rentabilité antérieures à 2008 et ce
au prix de la casse du service public
notamment hospitalier de
l'approfondissement des inégalités
madame la ministre prenez les mesures
qui s'imposent comment sinon imaginer la
suite
la justice sociale environnement table
environnementale sans ses moyens comment
imaginer que cette course aux folles au
profit n'a pas sa part de responsabilité
dans les crises multiples et en cascade
que nous vivons madame la ministre
êtes vous prête à prendre des mesures
strictes pour interdire le versement de
ses dividendes
je vous remercie merci madame la députée
la parole est à madame agnès bannière
une hache et secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'économie et des finances
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés manable de la
députée il faut sillon dans le contexte
du moment il est essentiel que chacun
fasse sa part chacun dans la mesure de
ses moyens et c'est le cas des
entreprises participer pour les
entreprises c'est continuer à faire
fonctionner le pays et aider à lutter
contre les coronavirus c'est très
exactement ce que font des dizaines des
centaines d'entreprises en distribuant
du gel hydro alcoolique sans prendre de
marge en s'asseyant sur leurs coûts de
développement pour faire des
respirateurs comme air liquide en
mettant à disposition pro bono un
certain nombre de leurs ressources et je
ne vais pas faire la longue liste des
entreprises qui aujourd'hui accompagne
l'ensemble des services hospitaliers
petites entreprises moyennes entreprises
est très grandes entreprises
keep 'lvmh type air liquide type et sa
type beaucoup d'entreprises qui sont
aujourd'hui au cac 40 et que vous visez
par vos propos participer c'est
continuer aussi à c'est aussi ne pas
recourir au dispositif de soutien mais
tu as quand on en a pas besoin
ça ça paraît essentiel encore faut-il le
faire participer ses consacrer ses
ressources et je pense que nous nous y
retrouverons au maintien de l'outil de
production à l'investissement dans cet
outil au moment du redémarrage et à
l'investissement dans les compétences de
des salariés et à ce titre des grandes
entreprises ont d'ores et déjà indiqué
qu'elle ne verserait pas de dividende en
2020 c'est le cas d'airbus et safran
dans le cac 40 c'est le cas de jc déco
d'europcar de cnp dans le sbf 120
c'est le cas de 70% des entreprises du
middle next et il est clair qu'il n'est
pas envisageable que les tiens ce que
l'état soutienne en trésorerie en
garantie des entreprises qui verseraient
du dividende
car il n'est pas question de financer
avec la garantie d'états du dividende
donc il y a un engagement pas de ne pas
verser des dividendes pour les
entreprises qui auraient beaucoup rom
dispositif d'état de ne pas procéder à
des rachats d'actions et de diminuer de
25 % la rémunération globale des
dirigeants sinon ce sera un
remboursement avaient
des pénalités de retard je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre
paroles de monsieur olivier marc l'ex
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre je vais vous livrer une
anecdote un peu navrante j'ai eu pas
plus tard qu'hier au téléphone un chef
d'entreprise de mon département
l'entreprise t ebay qui est un des trois
constructeurs français de l'ambulance je
devais sav leader dans les samu de santé
d'urgence et bien il me dit monsieur
marc l'ex vous devinerez jamais ce qui
est en train de faire l'administration
de l'assistance publique hôpitaux de
paris
cette semaine ils vont attribuer un
marché d'une centaine d'ambulances à un
constructeur polonais tout simplement
parce qu'ils n'ont pas mis le moindre
critère de développement durable dans
cet appel d'offres
combien de temps cela va-t-il durer
combien de temps resterons-nous les
idiots du village planétaire
comment ne pas voir à travers cette
crise même que nous vivons que la
connaissance par l'état de son outil
industriel que la protection par l'état
de son outil industriel que l'état de
cet outil industriel est un élément
déterminant de la capacité de réaction
de l'état dans la gestion de la crise
alors nous ne sommes pas chez les
républicains pour le repli national en
matière économique notre industrie comme
notre agriculture ont besoin de se
tourner vers le monde c'est ce qui a
fait toute leur histoire c'est ce qui
fait toute leur grandeur et c'est ce qui
fait la richesse de dieu d'un pays comme
le nôtre mais arrêtons de laisser filer
notre appareil productif au gré de
fusions acquisitions qui sacrifie nos
outils industriels arrêtons de croire
que les investisseurs n'ont pas de
passeport comme jeune et si souvent
entendu depuis deux ans nous en payons
aujourd'hui le prix fort alors à l'heure
où même la grande distribution monsieur
le premier ministre conseille d'acheter
français allez vous demandez à vos
services de changer enfin de logiciels
pour se tenir par l'achat nos propres
industries merci merci monsieur débuté
la parole à madame agnès pannier rina
chez secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'économie et des finances
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
marc l'ex fort heureusement nous n'avons
pas attendu cette crise pour nous
apercevoir que l'industrie était un
élément central de notre politique
économique et je veux rappeler ici que
c'est ce gouvernement qui a permis de
recréer de l'emploi industriel en france
puisque comme vous le savez
et de manière continue de 2000 à 2016
on a effectivement cassé l'appareil
industriel français avec la suppression
d'un million d'emplois industriels en
2017 en 2018 et en 2019 on a recréé de
l'emploi industriel
ça ce sont les faits en 2018
on est le premier pays européen pour les
investissements étrangers pour les
projets industriels sur la plus haute
marche du podium avec 330 projets contre
150 en allemagne et 200 en turquie ça ce
sont les faits et c'est comme ça que
nous continuons à travailler
comment a t'on mobiliser l'industrie sur
les respirateurs comment a t'on
mobiliser l'industrie sur les masques
comment mobilisons-nous aujourd'hui
l'industrie sur le pardon sur les
médicaments ou sur d'autres sujets comme
les blues puisque tout le monde est au
travail et je veux remercier ici les
équipes de la direction générale des
entreprises et de la direction générale
de la santé qui je peux vous dire à
chaque français quand elles le peuvent
s'agissant maintenant de votre question
figurez-vous que moi j'ai demandé depuis
le mois de juin nous animons à un comité
des acheteurs publics et privés pour
mettre en place de manière obligatoire
des clauses sociales et
environnementales dans tous les contrats
publics
donc on n'a pas attendu cette crise pour
s'en apercevoir et 7 est ce ces clauses
elles ont vocation à être mise dans les
cahiers des charges administratives
générales on considérera que le pacte
productif qui devait être présentée au
mois d'avril a été traîné et c'est
clairement un des éléments structurants
de ce pacte productif je pense que la
crise que nous traversons permettront de
raffermir encore ces dispositifs
merci mamie monsieur le député j'avais
quelques secondes pour répondre à
d'abord remarqué madame le ministre
visiblement n'a pas été entendue donc ça
peut passer le message
à l'assistance publique-hôpitaux de
paris elle sera la bienvenue et puis je
vais essayer de le dire avec calme
compte tenu des circonstances mais ce ne
sont pas ceux qui ont laissé filer
alstom alcatel technip ne sont pas ceux
qui avaient pour projet la privatisation
des dp ou le démantèlement
df ou celui de gdf qui sont les mieux
placés pour nous rassurer sur
l'attention qu'ils portent au
patriotisme économique à l'industrie
française
merci monsieur le député nous allons
terminer cette séance avec des questions
portant sur des thèmes divers toujours
en lien avec la crise sanitaire
à part le terme dames charlotte lecoq
pour monsieur morenas merci monsieur le
président donc c'est la question de mon
collègue adrien morena ce qu'a souhaité
y associer le député yves daniel et
cette question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'agriculture et de
l'alimentation monsieur le ministre
alors que la crise sanitaire ducobu 19
frappe nos contrées nos agriculteurs
héros du quotidien ne désarme pas afin
de continuer coûte que coûte à remplir
leur mission vitale pour notre pays nous
nourrir calamités agricoles dans
certains départements manque de
main-d'oeuvre fermeture de marché
alimentaire chute des demandes
concernant les produits frais alors que
le printemps arrive
la liste est longue à l'autre bout de la
chaîne d'approvisionnement les français
craignent parfois la pénurie alimentaire
monsieur le ministre regarde cette
situation inédite de crise sanitaire et
économique
le député adrien morenas souhaite vous
poser les questions suivantes
pouvez vous nous détailler comment le
gouvernement compte aider nos
agriculteurs locomotive essentiel de
notre chaîne d'approvisionnement
que ce soit dans le cadre de l'emploi de
personnel saisonnier que ce soit en
terme de soutien aux filières comme de
contrôle du marché national faso d'avis
financière sur les prix et enfin de par
les dispositions qui seront prises en
direction des banques comme des
assurances afin de soutenir nos
agriculteurs dont la tâche n'est jamais
facile
monsieur le ministre pouvez-vous
rassurer à nouveau les français sur
notre capacité collective à assurer la
pérennité des chaînes
d'approvisionnement alimentaire
merci merci la parole est à monsieur
didier guillot ministre de l'agriculture
de l'alimentation merci monsieur le
président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
je peux vous dire maintenant qu'il n'y
aura pas de pénurie alimentaire dans
notre pays
la priorité numéro 1 évidemment c'est la
santé de nos concitoyens c'est du thé
pour la santé de nos concitoyens c'est
ce que fait quotidiennement jour et nuit
le premier ministre ministre de la santé
que ces deux de rassurer de prendre des
mesures qui vont faire en sorte que le
coc vie de 19 que cette guerre soit
gagnée mais la deuxième priorité c'est
nos concitoyens puissent se nourrir
puisse se nourrir de façon la plus
diversifiée possible le plus équilibré
possible et c'est la raison pour
laquelle la deuxième ligne comme l'a
appelé le président la république et sur
place vevo qu'elle est les aviculteurs
je veux les les saluer vraiment ils sont
parfois critiqué injustement
mais là nous apercevons nous avons
besoin d'eux pour produire pour produire
de l'alimentation de qualité
et puis c'est toute la chaîne
alimentaire dont nous avons la
responsabilité qu'elle tienne
et elle tient après les agriculteurs je
voulais saluer les entreprises
intermédiaires les entreprises
d'agroalimentaire nos pme noté que la
coopération agricole qui sont parfois
montrés du doigt mais qui travaillent là
en trois huit jours et nuits bien
souvent et je veux saluer tous ces
travailleurs de l'ombre qui sont hors à
leur poste et qui permettent de
transformer les produits de
l'agriculture pour être sur nos dans nos
assiettes et puis enfin au bout de la
chaîne à laval il ya tous les commerces
de proximité des commerces alimentaires
les gms qui sont parfois vilipendé mais
aujourd'hui elles elles ont agi pour
faire en sorte que cela fonctionne je
veux saluer tous les salariés
toutes les questions tous ceux qui
mettent dans les rayons parce que sans
eux cette chaîne alimentaire ne
tiendrait pas il n'y aura pas de pénurie
alimentaire parce que la production est
là la chaîne alimentaire tient elle ne
sera pas rompue et c'est la raison pour
laquelle le gouvernement tous les jours
avec mon collègue bruno le maire et jean
baptiste djebbari nous travaillons pour
assurer cette continuité et notamment au
travers de la logistique et des
transports
avec muriel pénicaud et bruno le maire
nous avons mis en place une plate forme
permettant à celles et ceux de nos
concitoyens dans le cadre des mesures de
sécurité sanitaire qui voudraient aller
travailler en agriculture de pouvoir de
pouvoir le faire
enfin j'ai interpellé l'union européenne
pour que l'union européenne nous aide
dans les filières en difficulté comme
par exemple la pêche toute une filière
grande difficulté et comme
l'horticulture également et comme
d'autres mais j'aurai l'occasion d'en
parler plus avant une prochaine fois en
tout cas soyez assurés madame la députée
qu'il n'y aura pas de pénurie
alimentaire que la chaîne alimentaire
tient et que nos concitoyens doivent
s'alimenter en mangeant du poisson en
mangeant des produits frais et des
fruits des légumes et lorsque le premier
ministre est ferme les marchés ils les
fermes par mesure de sécurité et ceux
qui rient ou le font dans le cadre de
distanciation social journée merci
monsieur le ministre la parole est un
monsieur thierry benoit merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur je vais vous lire une
question de sophie auconie députée donc
du groupe e udi agir et indépendante
députée d'indre et loire
monsieur le ministre pour certains ou
certaines d'entre nous adultes comme
enfants
le confinement se révèle être un
véritable cauchemar et le foyer devient
tout bonnement le lieu de leur
séquestration légal dix jours après le
début du confinement
les interventions de la gendarmerie
suite à des violences intrafamiliales
ont augmenté de 32 % les services du 39
19 numéros d'urgence son maître maintenu
et nous remercions vivement les
écoutantes poursuivre leur mission
le numéro d'urgence est ouvert du lundi
au samedi de 9 heures à 19 heures or
nous savons malheureusement que les
violences interviennent majoritairement
le soir et le week-end
cette aide intervient d'ailleurs aux
mêmes horaires que les pharmacies dont
nous saluons vivement l'initiative mise
en place pour devenir pour venir en aide
aux victimes de violences alors que le
message national et restez chez vous
nous devons être vigilants et rappeler à
toutes les victimes de violence qu'il
est interdit de sortir mais qu'il est
autorisé de fuir
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur
comment fuir un conjoint violente
surtout avec des enfants quand les
proches susceptible d'offrir un refuge
sont loin quand les transports sont
aléatoires quand les hébergements
d'urgence structurellement déborder
peuvent difficilement garantir des
conditions de sécurité correcte face au
virus
de la même manière si l'accompagnement
des victimes peut toujours être assurée
par les services de police
est il encore possible compte tenu de
l'état de nos hôpitaux d'y faire établir
des constats médicaux de corps et de
coups et violences sexuelles
chaque jour le décompte glaçant des
victimes du coronavirus a remplacé celui
des féminicides nous connaissons
l'engagement du gouvernement sur ce
sujet et les récentes avancées en la
matière c'est pourquoi nous vous
demandons quels sont les moyens que vous
comptez mettre en oeuvre urgemment pour
protéger ses victimes de leurs tyrans je
vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole de
monsieur christophe castaner ministre de
l'intérieur merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les députés monsieur
le député thierry benoit
vous avez raison le confinement est
nécessaire pour lutter contre le coc
vite 19 mai il est un terreau qui peut
conduire à des violences intrafamiliales
qui sont évidemment un combat que nous
devons mener en permanence comme j'ai
deux questions je me permettrai
d'évoquer la réponse directe du
ministère des terres après avoir
réaffirmé le combat interministériel que
nous devons mener sous l'autorité du
premier ministre
est ce qu'on va nous devons l'emmener
sur l'ensemble des champs qui permettent
justement de lutter contre le risque
contre la souffrance contre la violence
il était évident que nous devons agir de
façon la plus transversale possible
c'est la raison pour laquelle marlène
schiappa la secrétaire d'état en charge
de ces sujets pour les violences faites
aux femmes a évoqué dès hier un plan
d'action avec plus d'un million d'euros
mobilisés pour accompagner les
associations qui sont là sur le terrain
aux côtés des victimes pour augmenter
les places d'hôtel et vous avez raison
c'est nécessaire d'avoir des réponses
urgentes soient pour l'éloignement du
conjoint violent soit pour la mise à
l'abri des victimes qui le souhaitent et
elle a aussi évoqué la nécessité de
créer des points d'accompagnement dans
des lieux du coma celui du quotidien qui
peut permettre justement à une femme
victime de violence alors même que l es
enfermé chez soi de profiter d'un moment
d'une sortie pour passer l'alertent de
la même façon adrien taki avec lequel
nous avions une réunion travail ce matin
porte aussi sur l'accompagnement des
enfants au sein des familles pour lutter
contre les maltraitances et notamment
pour favoriser la vigilance collective
et la possibilité de faire connaître le
numéro d'appel 119
pour que chaque enfant victime puisse
aussi pousser un cri d'alerté être
protégés enfin la garde des sceaux l'a
rappelé et c'est un principe absolu même
dans le combat que nous devons mener sur
le contre locaux vides 19 il n'est pas
question de baisser la garde et nous
devons mobiliser notamment la justice
pour le traitement des affaires de
violences intrafamiliales qui reste une
priorité et pour les audiences de
comparution immédiate
voilà monsieur le député quelques
éléments de réponse que je compléterai à
l'instant parce que nous devons faire en
sorte que le silence ne soit jamais le
complice de l'inacceptable
merci monsieur le ministre paroles et et
madame charlotte lecoq
merci donc ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur et
j'y associe également mon collègue
guillaume gouffier chat effectivement
cette question est proche de celle de
thierry benoit monsieur le ministre donc
ma question porte sur les violences
conjugales et intrafamiliales
pendant cette période de confinement les
tensions dans les foyers peuvent se
renforcer
la promiscuité dans les domiciles
l'absence de soupapes et d'échappatoire
les conduites addictives aggravent un
manque ablement de situations fragiles
les femmes mais également les enfants en
sont les premières victimes potentielles
c'est pourquoi il est indispensable de
maintenir plus que jamais notre
mobilisation contre les violences
conjugales et intrafamiliales
alors que ces victimes rencontreront des
difficultés pour se protéger ou fuir de
ces violences comment mettre fin à leur
calvaire et comment agir contre les
auteurs comment rendre possible pour ces
femmes et ces enfants d'appeler à l'aide
malgré les contraintes de sortie imposé
par le confinement et l'omniprésence de
leur agresseur comment avant tout
accompagné les familles pour prévenir ce
risque et éviter qu'une situation
dégradée ne bascule dans la violence
comment libérer la parole et apaisée des
situations conflictuelles dans les
foyers et enfin monsieur le ministre
comment chacun de nous
chaque citoyen peut-il apporter son aide
à ces personnes car même en période de
confinement il est de notre devoir à
tous de ne pas fermer les yeux merci
merci chers collègues la parole de
monsieur christophe castaner ministre de
l'intérieur merci monsieur le président
madame la députée je les dis nous devons
tous être mobilisés mais le ministère de
l'intérieur
évidemment une responsabilité
particulière pour répondre aux urgences
ça a été évoqué partir et benoît la
semaine dernière je donnais le chiffre
de 32 % en zone gendarmerie de 36% en
zone de la préfecture de police
d'augmentation des interventions de nos
forces de sécurité sur ce sujet
attention ça ne veut pas dire
d'augmentation des violences je parle
bien des interventions et comme des
interprétations ont été faites sur ce
chiffre il faut préciser cela mais nous
devons aller plus loin encore compte
tenu justement des circonstances
exceptionnelles que vous évoquez bien
sûr il y à la plateforme internet pour
avoir un portail de signalements ouvert
24 heures sur 24 avec des policiers ou
des gendarmes qui répondent 24 heures
sur 24 sollicitations mais j'ai dès la
semaine dernière
envoyez des instructions spécifiques aux
policiers aux gendarmes de notre pays
pour que un certain nombre de mesures
soient mises en oeuvre notamment par
exemple les appels d'initiative ce qui
n'est pas usage habituel mais un
policier un gendarme peut appeler une
femme dont on sait qu'elle est en risque
même si la procédure n'a pas fait en
sorte qu'elle soit séparée de son
conjoint ou parce qu'elle n'a pas porté
plainte parce qu'elle ne l'a pas
souhaité un appel une alerte une urgence
nous intervenons c'était le cas hier
dans la commune d'annoeullin ou après un
appel un appel badin de discussion le
gendarme a compris qu'il y avait un
risque des gendarmes sont intervenus et
nous avons mis à disposition de la
justice en vue d'une comparution
immédiate un mari violent
de la même façon nous avons sollicité
avec l'ordre des médecins des
pharmaciens la mobilisation des
pharmacies dans ce lieu de proximité où
on peut donner une alerte et à ce moment
là
les consignes sont simples immédiatement
on appelle les forces de sécurité
intérieure policiers aux gendarmes ils
interviennent immédiatement les
instructions a été clair hier à nancy un
cas elle peut être signalés ainsi et nos
forces ont pu intervenir immédiatement
mais nous devons aller encore plus loin
madame la députée parce que il y à
internet il y a le fait de sortir mais
quelquefois c'est impossible je souhaite
vous annoncer que en lien avec mes
collègues de gouvernement nous mettrons
en place à partir de demain la
possibilité de donner l'alertent par
simple texto pour que le texto puisse
donner une alerte et qu'ensuite les
forces de sécurité intérieure
interviennent c'est une proposition
d'ailleurs construite avec love qui est
président de la région auvergne
rhône-alpes qui m'a signalé la
disponibilité du 114 et de la plate
forme qui est gérée par des services
hospitaliers
de grenoble et qui nous permettra là
aussi par le 114 de donner l'alerté par
simple texto parce que en aucun cas le
confinement de la tête l'empêchement et
le fait de laisser des violences
conjugales ou des violences
intrafamiliales
merci monsieur le ministre madame lecoq
pour la question de madame anne gendt et
oui merci monsieur le président donc
cette collègue de cette question de ma
collègue anne jeune t'es associe
également les députés roland lescure et
christophe di pompéo et s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'europe et des
affaires étrangères pardon sur le sort
de nos compatriotes qui sont
actuellement bloqués à l'étranger
la pandémie que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui concerne tous les pays et
pour en limiter la propagation
nombre d'entre eux ont fermé leurs
frontières sans préavis
plongeant brutalement plus de 130 me de
nos compatriotes dans l'impossibilité de
regagner notre pays
les agents de votre ministère monsieur
ministres ont répondu à cette situation
aussi complexe que soudaine avec une
abnégation et un sang froid admirable
ils sont l'honneur de la france et au
nom de la représentation nationale
madame jeune t'es tiens à les remercier
en ce mardi 31 mars ils ont assuré le
retour de plus de cent mille citoyens
français dit de passage en visites
touristiques ou professionnels
et tandis qu'il redouble d'efforts pour
construire des solutions ajouté voudrais
signaler que certaines compagnies
aériennes
malgré votre demande de modération ont
cherché opportunément à profiter de la
situation avec des prix de billets en
classe éco très au delà des tarifs
habituellement observées cette situation
est inacceptable et vous l'avez dit
vous-même
on s'en souviendra et les français aussi
monsieur le ministre adjointe et
souhaiterait dès lors vous posez ces
trois questions quels sont les moyens
que l'état met en oeuvre pour ramener
ces français de passage toujours bloqués
à l'étranger
quel est le pouvoir de l'état dans ses
négociations avec les compagnies
aériennes pour qu'elles proposent des
vols commerciaux à prix coûtant et enfin
comment la france peut aider ces autres
naufragés du coc vide ses compatriotes
qui ont perdu leur titre de séjour parce
qu'il était lié à un emploi brutalement
supprimés par la crise et en particulier
nos jeunes en visa vacances travail en
australie et nouvelle zélande dont
beaucoup se retrouvent aujourd'hui sans
ressources
merci
merci mme nos députés la parole est à
monsieur jean yves le drian ministre de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères oui
madame la députée vous avez fixé le
cadre fermeture des aéroports fermeture
des frontières disparition progressive
des lignes régulières tout cela
généralement de manière brutale
fermeture des espaces aériens
avec pour résultat cent trente mille de
nos compatriotes bloqués souvent
d'ailleurs brutalement et sans avoir
qu'une capacité de réagir rapidement je
pense aux 20000 français qui était au
maroc il ya encore dix jours
face à cela nous avons mis en place un
dispositif exceptionnel indispensable
parce que c'est 130 mille ressortissants
français étaient localisés dans 140 pays
différents et je dois vous dire que
chaque pays
c'est un problème généralement c'est un
problème complexe et nous avons mis en
oeuvre un dispositif qui fait que avec
la collaboration étroite du ministère
des transports du centre de crise du
quai d'orsay et d'air france qui je veux
rendre hommage ici pour sa disponibilité
et sa coopération
un dispositif qui permet à la fois de
maintenir autant que faire se peut les
vols réguliers mais il faut à chaque
fois une autorisation à la fois de créer
des vols spéciaux dans des prix mesurée
modéré et troisièmement et nous faisons
de plus en plus nous affrétons nous
mêmes c'est à dire l'état affrète des
vols dans tout dans tous les pays y
compris des vols intérieurs dans chacun
des pays je pense aux philippines je
pense à opérons en particulier ou et les
français qui sont dans d'autres villes
que la capitale pour les ramener le plus
rapidement possible sur le territoire
national il reste aujourd'hui il restait
hier soit environ dix mille de nos
compatriotes qui étaient dans
l'impossibilité de revenir mais nous
irons jusqu'au bout du traitement de
chaque situation il faut qu'il le sache
même si c'est parfois un peu longs c'est
toujours très complexe je pense au
vanuatu je pense on n'est pas je pense
au guatemala à d'autres d'autres pays de
ce type qui sont très compliquées
l'autre question que management est
posée est différente c'est celle dvd pvt
en australie en nous
les landes ils ne font pas partie de ces
32 c 130 milles c'est un sujet sur
lequel je m'expliquerai avec elle et
nous allons trouver des solutions pour
éviter à ces jeunes la dpve était
d'avoir les conséquences trop graves de
du confinement qui s'est installé en
australie et en nouvelle-zélande merci
monsieur le ministre la séance des
questions au gouvernement est terminée
j'ai reçu à l'application des articles l
aux 100 76 lots 179 du code électoral
une communication du ministre de
l'intérieur en date du 30 mars 2020
m'informant du remplacement de notre
regretté collègue jean-françois cesarini
par madame souad zitouni je vous
remercie de sortir de manière échelonnée
prochaine séance mardi 7 avril à 15h
questions au gouvernement la séance est
levée